e
like to welcome representative cabro and
we do have another one who's not here
yet representative
Johnson uh before we get started
representative would you like to lead us
Allegiance flag of the United States of
America to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
thank you for
[Music]
right 581 I'm assuming you must be M Mr
fette and I assume the senator can't be
with us today okay hold on all right so
I just want to know who I'm introducing
to open uh to uh introduce the bill okay
so I'm going to open up the public
hearing on Senate Bill 598 FN requiring
funeral possession lead vehicles to obey
yield signs uh as you just heard the
senator can't join us so introducing the
bill is a representative for her uh
chair recognizes Dy Fett
welcome thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee my name is dy fette and
I'm the Senate majority caucus director
uh Senator Chari was unable as you heard
Senator shardi is unable to introduce
the bills today so she asked me to do it
on her behalf
Senate Bill 598 FN will require funeral
possession lead vehicles to obey yield
signs Senator Chari was asked by her
constituent Mark corer who owns corer
funeral home and Cremation Center in
Jaffrey to file this bill which will
make a technical addition to the current
statute RSA
26556 regarding funeral possessions this
bill was recommended ought to pass by
the Senate Transportation committee by a
vote of four to zero and subsequently
was passed by the bill the Senate passed
the bill on a vot Voice vote thank you
for allowing me the opportunity to speak
this morning senatori thanks you for
your consideration and if you have any
questions I'll be sure to pass them on
to her so we can get you some
answers all right thank you did you say
you can't take any questions or won't
take questions I I can't answer any
questions but I'll be happy to get senat
get the questions to Senator Chari so
you can get some all right any questions
from the
committee represent
London yes thank you um little history
I'm the one that actually drafted the
legislation for the funeral procession
with the uh purple lights and the signs
and the certain signage and everything
so I'm familiar with with with the
legislation this is adding on to um and
I do concur it I mean it makes sense to
have the lead vehicle U yield or or
follow uh uh stop signs and and lights
and everything
um I just want to make sure that this
does not it uh mean that the procession
itself
has to start it's that lead vehicle and
the other vehicles can follow Sue
sometimes there a large uh processions
and if all the vehicles have their uh
signage or Flags it should be a safe
process I I don't know if you can answer
that but I just want to make sure that
uh it's primarily lead Vehicles the rest
can follow sou yeah absolutely um I will
ask Senator shardy I can give her a call
after this and I can find out an answer
for you and we can uh get you that
answer thank you Mr
chair any other questions representative
friend good morning my question is um if
they have uh law enforcement at the head
of the possession will that
requirement again I will uh I will talk
to sh didn't get back to you thank
you who are the questions representative
Jones Thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I know you can't
answer um Absolut isn't isn't this
already the law all vehicles are
supposed to be found following
all all
laws so I don't know if this is
necessary I I know the procession is
allowed to follow lead car but the lead
car is supposed to follow all current
traffic laws okay so I don't know if
this is necessary but um I'd be
interesting to hear an answer back on
that yeah thank you for your question
and again I will get back to you with
that thank you Mr
chair anybody else I'll give you one
more for the senator what are you
supposed to do with a yield sign do you
have to stop or if there's nobody coming
can you just continue to which if the
second is true I'm not sure why this is
needed
any other questions seeing none thank
you uh next up chair recognizes Peter
Moren representing the New Hampshire
funeral director's Association in
welcome on or not uh good morning uh
chairman W members of the committee
thank you very much for taking the time
to uh to take my testimony today uh my
name is Peter Warren I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Funeral
Directors Association here in New
Hampshire um and I'm also a licensed
funeral director and in Balmer uh we
have over 200 licensed Funeral Directors
who are members and actually currently
all of the funeral homes actually I
think there are two that are not members
of our association uh but I'm here in in
support of U Senate Bill 598 FN uh we're
very grateful for the Senator's uh
sponsorship of of this and introduction
of this bill and of her her staff here
to to do that today um this bill uh is
basically uh housekeeping if you will
that back in 2002 when the original
legislation which we needed desperately
at the time and thank you very much for
your service and writing that um is uh
didn't seem to didn't even occur to us
that it needed to include yield signs
what's happened and I think the
representative from Kean will know is I
think in Kean we have about seven
roundabouts or traffic circles now that
there more and more roundabout traffic
circles rotaries whatever you might call
them which we really didn't have very
many uh a number of years ago and
now as with including funeral
processions if we can allow that lead
car and yes the funeral uh funeral
processions would remain with the lead
car um and uh so that this would would
uh because with the roundabouts and the
traffic circles is that they're all the
control and that of that traffic is all
done by yield signs all of them even in
in Central Square and Kean we have three
entrances that are by traffic lights but
they're two by yield signs so but uh and
so it's a matter of just having it work
out so the procession stays together but
that that lead car you know will yield
to that sign and the rest of the
procession will go with it uh again I
mean with due caution you know as we
knew when they we first did the big one
on one1 in in Keen there was quite a
learning curve to any kind of traffic
circle around about I mean the police
were called out daily to offender
benders with that but um so we're really
just looking to to do this bit of
housekeeping um and I think I can answer
the other questions if you like but um
so we're here to to navigate to uh to
support this and uh we think it's just a
very simple fix so we appreciate your
time and I'll be happy to try to answer
any
questions thank you sir questions from
the committee representer
Fox thank you Mr chairman um in thank
you for taking my
question what does the lead car
currently do if they don't yield do they
oh they would yield yes they do yield
it's putting it in in statute where the
other the other means of regulating
funeral processions this this uh this
legislation is specifically for funeral
processions and uh it's like that once
we uh go into an intersection and we
follow you know with a light we can go
through the intersection when we stop
and check and then the rest of the
procession can stay with the lead car
even though the light may turn red or
whatever they they have that they have
that status if you will to to remain
with the uh um with the lead car and
again it's all done with with due
caution and common sense of course I
mean you know the law I don't I don't
argue with the laws of physics myself
so yeah follow y follow up thank you um
and I'm as I'm reading the the uh the
bill it is just the addition of yield
signs and yield the current the bill is
is uh remains untouched other than that
thank you unchanged yes yeah yeah
because again as I said before because
all of the traffic circles this type of
um traffic pattern um is all controlled
by yield signs and U thanks you bring up
a good point I guess with the Advent of
the as a
roundabouts not of which I'm a big fan
of by the way for these reasons how big
a problem do you have with the rest of
the people not yielding and just joining
your procession because they refuse to
stop in the middle of a roundabout right
most well as you pointed out before if
they have their their lights in their
flat the lead car would have lights or
the F the hearse would have lights their
their strobes their purple strobes um
the cars have uh funeral flags of course
as we know nowadays you know well we see
more often than not the drivers aren't
paying attention to anything but what's
going on with them um but um but most
what we found in New Hampshire is that
most people are incredibly
courteous uh they're very very you know
very thoughtful very and they will yield
to the and and the main the hard the
hardest problem we have in a funeral
procession is keeping the cars close
enough together because you'll be
surprised strobes or not I mean I've had
cars pull in between the hearse and the
lead car I mean like and we had to
police escort then that was through
Peterboro uh the other the other
question I think you did have was about
the police uh police escort I know Mark
has Mark canoer and Jaffrey has a he was
a former law enforcement he has a very
close relationship with the Jaffrey PD
and the Peto PD locally um but of course
we can have that all arranged which is
ideal and particularly like in Keane you
know we have a lot of traffic and so
forth a lot of traffic circles uh if we
have the the police escort that's ideal
but as we know they may be scheduled to
do that but they get called away uh then
they're not going to be there so we have
to navigate on our own uh and so if we
have this it gives us that legal
Authority that we have the right of way
after we yield at the yield sign and the
procession can go through yeah anybody
else represent
Gorski thank you Mr chairman and thank
you uh for taking my question so I'm
still kind of confused
if the the lead driver is yielding right
um in currently right
now why why do why is this why is this
bill
needed well I would I believe it's
needed
because uh again with the new traffic
patterns with traffic circles and
roundabouts U that we haven't addressed
those specific traffic patterns uh
because as I said yield signs aren't in
the statute at the time at now they're
not they presently not there and uh so I
guess being under the funeral procession
uh statute is that then gives the
procession The Authority or the
permission to follow the lead car as
they would through a typical
intersection with traffic lights or
whatever I mean once they establish um
sometimes we will have a car a separate
car which will actually help not sure if
this is entirely legal but actually
block coming oncoming traffic from both
directions if we have particularly if
it's a higher speed highway kind of
thing but yeah so I don't know if that
answers your question okay you're
welcome
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question do you know if there's a fine
for this if you break into the uh well
technically yes there is um but I think
it's I think it's rarely enforced I mean
if we sometimes we'll do we may get
we'll get a plate I mean of course we're
in a procession we're driving a car you
know we have the family there behind us
and have the hearse and the other
vehicles and like I said that when I had
in Peterboro I mean it was only a short
time they came off Pine Street because
there was like 10 ft between me and the
lead car and they and it was an elderly
driver she just slipped right in there
and did a great job but then we got down
to but we got down to where they were
doing the construction more than just
maybe 400 500 feet away and that's when
she went off One Direction we went the
rest of the way but uh although by then
I think there was a police car behind
her at that point U so whether they
spoke with her or not I don't know I
don't think she was even aware of
what I shouldn't speculate sorry follow
up I'm not getting yeah follow up thank
you um I see in the fiscal note it talks
about under the current law there's a
violation level penalty with a $100 fine
yield who would under this
law who would pay that
fine would that
vehicle for
failing um well I guess in the case of
any any vehicle involved in the funeral
procession um if the responsibility
would would go to the funeral
home yeah we'll mean we're we're in
charge of the procession I mean we we
can't determine what everyone else does
in the procession of course um uh I mean
I've worked in other other are is not
here in New Hampshire but in when I was
in school and I mean I had people go up
on the sidewalk to get around a funeral
procession I kid you not I kid you not
this is yeah
yes that's a good question I think we'll
look at the rest of the chapter I think
this deals with the processions
themselves but what happens to somebody
who breaks the procession could be
different thing and we have
representative pondon thank you Mr chair
yeah just for clarification the original
legislation that $100 fund is for a
vehicle not yielding to the procession
itself so cutting in so and again to
address uh the comments made that the
issue is enforcement you know if a
police officer sees it U then they can
issue the citation but
U so that I just wanted to clarify no
appreciate thank you for the
clarification representative Jones Thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question very um
I'm very familiar with king um I was
part of all those roundabouts that did
go in there uh but um many of the
roundabouts don't have signage it's the
law is you yield to the to those in the
circle right and but that's not
mentioned in this
it I'm not really sure to be honest with
you I mean um yes I do yeah I see what
you're saying
but I'm trying to think I'm not and I
mean I'm thinking when I I look back I
mean that's there's so much signage you
know they've done a new one on on U
Winchester Street uh a smaller one in
Island Street which is they're doing the
bridge work and that's all I all I can
see is signage you know about yield and
and which I don't know but yeah like
some of the ones like on Court Street is
there a followup don't have it I'm sorry
uh well they do have yes they I Sor I
don't mean to cont they do have yield
signs uh at each entrance uh Court
Street from the hospital entrance um oh
what's the other the other Road um
coming in but I believe they do I
believe they do I don't mean mean to
contradict you but I believe I go up
Court Street all the time so I live in
Sur so thank you Mr chair yeah and you
raised a good point uh I know the
Department of Transportation isn't here
now but they will be here later so
perhaps we can get the answer from them
and determine whether or not you think
something needs to be added to this one
yeah and we'd be we'd be welcome to we'd
be open to any any you know helping with
any changes like that anything anything
we can do to make it better okay fair
enough anybody else from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you very much having nobody else signed
uh up to speak I'm going to close the
598 we ran over on that one which means
we're going to be in trouble today um
okay um being 523 I'm going to open up
the public hearing on Senate Bill
582 which is relative to providing an
alternate address to the Department of
Motor Vehicles uh without the senator
present chair
bill hello again Mr chairman members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Daley Fett and I'm the Senate
majority caucus director and I'm here
this morning to introduce set up Bill
582 on behalf of Senator
shardi Senator shardi was asked to
present this bill by the DMV this bill
permits residents to use an alternate
mailing address with the DMV when absent
from their residence for less than six
months several years ago when the DMV
implemented temporary licenses in the
process of mailing the permanent license
they recognized the amount of New
Hampshire residents that were out of the
state during or or around their renewal
time many were snowbirds going south for
the winter months or students away at
College internally they implemented a
process where these applicants could
fill out a temporarily away form with
their out of state information as well
as the reason they would be out of state
to have their new hampsher license or ID
mailed to that out ofate address this
form was eventually assigned a form
number DSM V V5 94 and began to be used
in all bureaus for any DMV document that
was applied for and needed to be mailed
while the applicant was away for example
titles and boat
registrations the only exception to this
was has always been the original or the
firsttime license or ID card obtained in
New Hampshire is mailing the original
credential to a New Hampshire address is
an important part of confirming
residency in the
state under new Administration it was
recognized that the temporarily away
process is not defined in in statute the
DMV believes this process is beneficial
to the residents of the state and wants
to formalize the process in statute the
DMV will be will then further Define the
form used and information requested on
through uh administrative
rulem thank you again for allowing me
the opportunity to speak this morning if
you have any uh questions for me I can
be happy to take them back to Senator
rardy and Senator shardy thanks you for
your
consideration thank you if we you know I
didn't ask this before but if we have
questions when are we going to get the
answers uh I will as soon as possible
SE thank you thank you for taking my
question U I was concerned on the last
part about uh not sending out the uh
original driver's license or ID card uh
does this include the plates as
well uh you had mentioned something
about titles and other registration
information so was a little unsure
exactly what was included there thank
you okay
thank you for the
question any other questions
representative
chairman is there a do not
forward message currently being used on
instances thank you for the question and
I I'll get back to
you yeah and we do have somebody from
the Department of Vehicles here to get
some of those questions answered I
believe I believe that is the case other
questions
that may be able to wait DMV or you have
another
one I'm not I'm not sure if this needs
it can be answered by DMV um thank you
for taking my
question I'd like to know why the the
normal post office uh
forwarding um that's used
um I understand but thank you um I just
would like to hear what the what the
purpose for this is that isn't covered
by uh the normal forwarding process
through the post office I'd be happy to
get back to you on that thank
you okay oh yes represent Crawford thank
you for taking my question that
introduction that you read could I get a
copy of that absolutely thank you very
much I can send the committee a copy of
my written
testimony representative Club thank you
Mr chairman um if we could get at least
if not from Senator ricardi um from the
Department of Transportation some idea
of what that's going to look like
because from my standpoint it sounds
like we're going to be considering
adding a whole bunch of additional
government to to be able to make that
happen and I'm I'm just asking what does
that look like to create this well we
again we do have somebody from the
Department of Motor Vehicles who's going
to testify next and maybe we can ask her
the same question and get an answer all
right thank you any representative
pondon yes thank you Mr chair I think of
taking a question my only concern is
where it states on on line 13 alternate
mailing address outside of New Hampshire
to me that's kind of vague uh a lot of
the snowbirds and so on are use Campers
or they're tenting or whatever say they
go down south for the snowbirds um
should that specifically say a physical
address um for those that are mobile
while they're gone for the less than six
months um I don't want this to be an
excuse or whatever there's got to to me
there's got to be a physical location a
post office box or something where they
can retrieve their mail
would be my
concern thank you Mr chair again we have
somebody from the Department of Motor
Vehicles that's coming up next uh this
also is subject to RSA 541 which means
that uh for the details the department
usually does go through the rules
process to Pro a specific in info but
we'll find out what DMV says in a minute
anybody else from the committee seeing
none thank you very much thank you Mr
chair
that being said next up chair recognizes
Jennifer Bailey from the Department of
bill did you get all those questions yes
I them all down um good morning my name
is Jennifer Bailey I'm one of the
administrators for the Department of
Motor Vehicles um I don't have much more
to introduce to the bill he did a very
good job on what the reasoning is that
we're requesting this as for so your
questions so plates um we the only thing
we restrict from this form using is for
original driver's license because that's
in statute that we mail that to your New
Hampshire residents to prove that you're
a New Hampshire resident upon that but
anything else original we do allow you
to use this form to mail out of
state second question New Hampshire um
DMV mail is all mail with a no
forwarding um requirement on it so our
mail does not forward due to the Privacy
Law and stuff that we are mailing we're
mailing credentials we're mailing titles
um if those are forwarded to the wrong
location for example we've seen many
times that a husband and wife are
separated one forwards their mail the
post office forwards both their males so
that's why we do not forward our mail so
we created this alternative way for
people to receive their DMV documents by
physically telling us where they're
going to be they're signing a document
um there was one question about the um
process what that looks like we have
been doing this for I would say
approximately 12 to 15 years already
this is again us doing a cleanup Act of
actually putting it in statute so we
have a form they put their name their
New Hampshire information they're
putting the term that they're going to
be out of state which we do Max that
term at six months that they're still
considered a resident of the state um
they then list the alternative mailing
address we do not change their address
in the system we have a third address um
location in our computer that we can
list an A A temporarily away away
address and we even put the dates in the
system so that when those dates have
bypassed then their mailes no longer
going to that temporary location so
there it would there would be no new
procedure created we've already been
doing this for many
years where did I
miss
um I believe that's it I think I hit
them all but I do have a question for
you a couple of them actually yeah um
you this is news to me you've been doing
this for 12 to 15 years in terms of
mailing out most of the information not
but except the originals yes I had a
constituent a couple of years ago who
does the same thing moves to Florida
every year for the winter months and
could not get the title of his
motorcycle sent to him in Florida
because of the do not
forward uh policy and was told over over
and over and over again that they would
not send it to Florida so if we've been
doing this for 12 to 15 years why did we
almost give this guy a heart attack two
years ago so that I'm not sure because
we have been originally it was only
driver licensing that only lasted for a
few years though um then we implemented
in all of our bureaus um boats
especially Massachusetts residents
registering their boats during off
season um so I do not know why he was
turned down unless he had not completed
that form again we don't have it written
anywhere in statute um we do have it
listed on our website so if he was in
Florida he wouldn't have any way to get
the form is that a possible scenario
that is a possible scenario we do have
it online now and it can be mailed in um
we also allow you if you are out of
state to and processing your transaction
through mail to mail that form in along
with your transaction okay I was again I
was just hoping this was a solution to
that issue because that was a it would
was a one y uh any other questions from
the
committee representative plon thank you
and I maybe I didn't understand
everything but I don't think my question
was answered or I didn't explain it
clear enough my concern is where you've
been doing this is uh snowb Birds they
don't necessarily go to one Campground
yep so how do we handle say they're at a
campground in Clear Water for two weeks
then they go to Miami for three weeks
then they go you know they're traveling
around
you only have room for one forwarding
address and I'm assuming it's a it's a
you know physical location how do we
handle that or do we limit them or we
don't limit it's whatever address they
put down as a mailing so they can have a
PO Box in that state that they can go to
it doesn't have to be a physical
location it's just a mailing so it can
be PO Box it can be a friend of theirs
family that lives down the area it's
just whatever address they are providing
us and followup followup and it's been
successful for these 12 15 years no
absolutely excellent thank you Mr
chair how have you been doing this for
statute no
comment any other questions from the
committee yeah representative Gorski
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question can you give us the
form number that you're referring to on
this yes it's the DS smv
594 um it's on our website listed under
every Bureau now as the temporarily away
form that was dsmd um v as a motor
vehicle DSM MV MV thank
you anybody else seeing no seeing none
thank you very much thank you um I have
nobody else signed up to speak on Senate
hearing and we've got five minutes till
e
okay being
1040 open up the public hearing on
Senate Bill 471 FN relative to adding a
speed limit of 45 miles hour on Rural
highways chair recognizes the prime
sponsor Senator Waters good morning
thanks you so much Mr chairman Senator
David Waters District Four coming over
from Senate transportation to house
transportation to introduce uh Senate
Bill 471 um relative to the speed limits
um the bill itself as you'll see on the
first page is pretty simple it
introduced in into the statute a middle
ground speed limit in Statue between the
35 and the 55 um this bill uh is
necessary because the Department of
Transportation needs legislative
authority to set 45 miles an hour
instead of 55 um under current
statute um there's a distinction between
Suburban and Rural speed limits that's
why we get the 35 and the uh 50 55 but
there really are just some roads where
that 55 no matter what the engineering
you know with its template may say uh
situations have developed where the 55 M
hour limit um is really not appropriate
for that that road um I will just
mention and I'm sure all of you have
your District's roads that might come
into this situation on Route four coming
out of Dover heading over towards um
South
Berwick uh it's it's a good road well
wellmaintained um to Lane a 55 mile hour
but there were just a series of just
Grievous fatal accidents on that road
over a number of years and since its
first designation um as the the Rural
Road uh more curb Cuts more housing more
housing developments even with a
flashing light uh one intersection
coming over a hill where there you are
and that's where one of the most
horrible uh accidents happen so um to
petition Rollins Rollinsford to petition
to have that be made into a slightly
lower speed limit was an extraordinary
process uh and took a couple years and
there was another accident in the
meantime um so this would just give this
tool to the department um they they'd
like to have this and the rest of the
bill just how things kind of fall out as
to the Fine structure and so on and uh
and so forth
um and uh the department as you will
hear um thinks this would be very
helpful to them to give them this
flexibility um there certainly uh would
be a robust process in terms of DET
determining a a road that was
appropriate for this working with the
local communities who are most likely to
be the ones who will bring forward
requests uh such as such as this um this
is not meant to be as a re-evaluation of
all of our roads in the state it's just
as a tool that when requests come up
there'll be in statute this possibility
of the dot keeping keeping people safe
and protecting our municipalities um so
uh Mr chairman I'm glad to talk about it
more but I really think that the folks
in the department here can give you a
lot more about the ins and outs about
how we have applied the previous statute
and why this change is needed thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee seeing then thank you so much
back to hearings and I will return we
will see you soon y uh next up chair
recognizes Senator Carson representing
Senate District 14 uh not taking a
position on the
bill unless you are I think I please
correct that I'm in strongly I strongly
support this bill okay that's why I'm
here I'll put the check down I think my
Aid when he filled it out just usually
he doesn't fill that part out
good morning Mr chairman and good
morning members of the House
Transportation committee for the record
my name is Sharon Carson I have the
pleasure of representing Senate District
14 which comprises the town of towns of
Auburn London Derry and Hudson and I'm
here today in in strong support of this
piece of
legislation um route 102 runs right
through London dairing it um it connects
to exit four um on Route 93 so you can
imagine it is a well traveled Road um
over the past few years I would say
eight
years it's changed everything has
changed when we first moved to London
Derry 35 years ago it was kind of like
you'd get some traffic on 102 during the
busy times of the day but for most of
the part you really minimal traffic in
fact there was a beautiful rest area
with a pump and uh London Dairy was
known for its water the pureness of its
water and people would go and they'd
bring jugs and they'd pump water and
take it
home that London Dairy doesn't exist
anymore it's gone and there have been a
102 it's become in my opinion Fair
pretty
dangerous um especially between West
Road which is right at the Town Line
with London Derry and Lichfield and
Route 102 the speed limit is 55 miles an
hour until you approach more the more
dense area where there are businesses
and it goes down to 40 now you can
imagine 55 people are not going 55
they're going 65 70 miles an hour we're
seeing an increase of traffic accidents
on this road um and what really spurred
um the real interest in this was we had
a fatality um a young man who had just
graduated from the adult education class
was pulling out from a side road he got
hit and he was killed there was a huge
outcry from my community um there was an
online petition with well over a
thousand signatures that something needs
to happen so I pulled together a meeting
with commissioner Cass along with our
town officials to have a discussion
about what can we do in this instance
can we slow down the traffic he informed
us of this bill and told us this is
coming through it's p the Senate we need
it to pass the house so I'm here to ask
you to please pass this bill it would
give the state the ability to lower the
the speed limit on Route 102 in London
Dairy and help to make it safer for our
communities I I think a big problem is
the drivers as well everybody's in a big
hurry to get everywhere and people are
disregarding what are the long terms of
the road um I can't tell you the number
of times I've been on Route 102 and I've
been passed on the right side um we've
been we've talked about can we expand
102 in this area and have turn Lanes
well no I don't think that's going to
work because of eminent domain they're
going to have to go in and take property
and I think all of you know how
difficult it is so it seems the best
thing that we can do at this point is to
lower the speed limit we also have uh
you know police are willing to enforce
but one of the things that I learned
during this meeting was we had our fire
chief there and we built a new fire
station along
102 they had at times they can't get out
they can't get out onto 102 that they
have to actually go around the backway
to get on to 102 because we cover um 93
when there are automobile
accidents and I see that as minutes lost
in saving lives so please I'm asking you
can we lower the the speed limit can you
support this legislation and help a town
like London
that's really struggling with traffic
issues on 102 and please pass this bill
so we can lower the speed limit thank
you very
much thank you any questions from the
committee I I just have one um not to be
argumentative the bill is specific to
unimproved rural highways and I'm just
curious if the section of Road you were
just referring to from West Road to Exit
4 most of what I know of 102 is improved
um we were thank you for the question Mr
chairman we were told that this bill
would fix the problem from the
commissioner so um I also have here and
I can make available because I can get
um uh I can get the information again
this was an analysis that was done in
March of this year and it's an accident
analysis of um Na it's called Nashville
Road that's what it was known years ago
um and I'll just submit it to the
committee when my husband was young um
they used to come up to London Dairy to
this pool store and that part of 102 was
actually a dirt road back in the early
1960s
so that's how much everything has
changed thank you very much thank you
chairman uh next up J recognizes
representative is that turber tur tur
those AR both ours okay representative
Terror in support of the bill
representing Rockingham
6 looking for five minutes but you don't
need all five NOP noome um thank you Mr
chair members um again my name for the
record Eric tur representative Eric tur
from Rockingham 6 which is Brentwood um
I think a lot of my comments will Echo
what what you just heard
um uh I'm here basically on behalf of
our planning board and our chair uh
Christen Al who had hoped to come today
but wasn't able uh to attend um there's
been an ongoing conversation in our town
uh with the Department of Transportation
um and uh uh executive councelor Stevens
has come to a couple of meetings in our
town regarding Route
125 um which is a North South Road that
basically goes from Massachusetts border
up through New Hampshire um you know a
as was said many years ago was probably
a you know you know a a very um a much
less busy road than it is now um the in
my town there are three um Key Road
Crossings North Road Middle Road South
Road that's how brentwood's built um and
along that stretch there are many curb
cuts um there are many businesses there
are homes where there are still school
bus stops um and increasingly number of
developments that directly attach to the
road um it is Zone commercial
um uh and I understand that it that it
would qualify under the definition for
this again from the Department of
Transportation um it's it's become so
dangerous um that a lot of people just
avoid Crossing it other than at the one
light that's been installed a few years
ago um there's almost almost annually
one or more fatal accidents on that
stretch of road and there there's
currently a an intersection that they're
trying to figure out what to do with um
so at those Town
meetings um the Department of
Transportation actually raised this bill
as something that they needed in order
to address the the speed problem as part
of not the entire solution to to what's
going what's going on in our town
um the reason they said this is needed
and and I think this is important is uh
the only other way to lower the speed
limit is to do a a speed study of the
road and basically they said we use this
I guess what's considered an somewhat uh
Arcane process of the 85th percentile of
of the cars going through um and because
the road essentially is now used almost
as a highway um it's estimated they
estimate that that the result of that
would actually likely increase rather
than decrease the speed limit on on
those section of Road and they they
don't have another option the only other
option would be to create a commercial
Zone through the middle of town and then
that would drop the speed limit down to
35 which I don't think any of us think
is the is the right number so this
basically provides an option that the
Department of Transportation said uh
again there will be studies I I assume
but but that that they think would be uh
applicable to the situation going on in
Brentwood and hopefully you know
contribute to making this this road um
somewhat safer um than it is today so
I'll I'll end with that but I'm glad to
take any questions to the extent that I
can answer them thank you any questions
from the committee seeing none thank
you representative of St Clair thank you
Mr chair um I just glanced at the uh
causation of accidents that report that
the uh Senator gave us did you have a
chance to look at
that I have not like I said uh
originally uh my planning board chair
Kristen aldred was was going to attend
uh but she wasn't able to make it so um
I I've talked with her quite a bit but I
haven't seen that report is there is
there something particularly in it that
that I I would encourage you to look at
that thank you oh I certainly will
thanks anybody else from the
much uh next up chair recognizes
representative melier so in support of
the
[Music]
thank you chairman Walsh and members of
the transportation committee uh again
for the record my name is Chris melier I
represent Carroll County District 2
which includes the town of
Albany
um couple weeks ago I got a uh a
petition from the town of of Albany they
wanted to reduce the speed limit on
Route 16 from 50 m hour to 40 m an hour
now as it turns out they tried to do
this back in uh in September of
20122 the Department of Transportation
did a major study and they would not
reduce the speed limit to 40 miles an
hour um when I heard about this bill 45
miles an hour I talked to the selectman
at at Aly and I think that they would
accept this as a reasonable
compromise uh I don't know how many of
you tra Route 16 that much um but from
uh where the the the four-lane highway
ends uh and be and the regular Road
begins in Wakefield that's the improved
section of 16 back in the old days you
had to go through Milton and Union and
it was uh really a unimproved road there
other sections of Earth 16 that are
improved but the section through Alban
has not been improved a couple years ago
there was talk about a major widening
and straightening of the road that has
not happened um it is a hilly road it is
uh a lot of turns on it in in some
sections there's very little uh you know
sighing to it um the these people in
Albany are very very concerned they've
had a number of accidents the most
recent accident I believe was a was a
head-on um where a eight eight-year-old
kid was was killed uh this is their Main
Street this is their Main Street um I'm
hoping that you pass the bill and
that'll give the town the opportunity to
petition the state to to review the road
again and hopefully we can get it get
the speed limit down to 45 miles an hour
um I thank you very much if anybody has
any
questions thank you thank you questions
from the committee seeing
now okay for lots of answers chair
recognizes Bill Lambert from the primary
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record uh my name is
Bill Lambert I'm the state administrator
for the dot uh office of Highway Safety
and active Transportation with me today
is Amanda Joe zeka she is our uh senior
highway safety engineer and she's also
our internal subject matter expert on
crashes so first time to the legislature
I figur i' put her in the hot seat with
me um so um a previous chair of this
committee reminded me that folks in this
uh committee do not need me to read the
testimony so I've handed out the
testimony that was signed by
commissioner
Cass uh and I'll try to summarize as
briefly as I can I know you have some
time constraints the first thing I want
to do is I want to dispel the notion
that the dot set speed limits on state
highways we do not the folks in this
body set speed limits statutory speed
limits are determined by RSA
26560 Loosely based on the context and
character of the highways so there's
three statutory speed limits in that
statute four if you count the
interstates but we're not talking about
them you've got a 35 a 30 m hour speed
limit for urban residence District or
business district and business district
doesn't necessarily mean commercial like
101a in that in Nash to Milford it's
more of the downtown Main Street
conquered
environment uh and then Urban res
District would be the street system
that's here in conquer um 35 M hour
would be the statutory speed limit for a
rural residence District which is a
pretty dense Suburban development it
doesn't match most of the roads and in
statute speed limits for other locations
are 55 miles an hour so arguably uh the
legislative body has left the majority
of State highways um in that other Lo
that other condition and for most of us
55 milph for most of those roads is not
appropriate the commissioner of
Transportation does have the authority
to alter from the statutory speed limits
in RSA
26562 however that's required to be
based on an engineering and traffic
investigation and that's kind of what
you've heard so far is that more often
than not when we conduct an engineering
and traffic investigation it does not
support lower speed
limits uh I want to make it clear that
this statute this bill does not address
class five roads under Town jurisdiction
so the 26560 also says that class five
highways outside of compact parts of
cities and towns is 35 miles an hour so
town roads are either going to be 30 mil
an hour in the compact parts of the town
or city or 35 so we're only talking
about State highways with this
buil um the fact that we've got that Gap
from 35 to 40 to 55 in the statutory
speed limits over the last 100 years or
whatever it is that that we've had the
statute uh has resulted in I think some
arbitrary reductions and loose
interpretations of the commissioner's
Authority so that if you're driving on
state highways and you see speed limits
of 40 45 or 50 by definition those are
State speed zones determined by the
commissioner of Transportation I would
say that a lot of those have been
lowered that they're not consistent um
so what we're really looking to do here
is is determine the legislative intent
for the statutory speed limit for the
majority of State highways we don't have
a plan to go out and proactively review
all of the speed limits but having that
statutory value gives us a tool so then
we get some of the roads that we've
heard about this already this morning uh
and many more throughout the state we
can first identify what the the
statutory speed limit is we don't need
the engineering and traffic
investigation to change the speed limit
if it per statute um but we would have
that tool um and it's not always going
to going to be about lowering speed
limits I can point to a couple examples
um the first one I would talk uh I would
point to is New Hampshire 120 from
clamont to Lebanon and I know
representative Sykes is probably
familiar with that and probably others
are as well um we had gotten a request
several years ago from the village of
Cornish Flats to lower the speed limit
but because 120 is pretty much a
homogeneous Road from Claremont to to
Lebanon we looked at the whole Corridor
and I want to say that there's eight or
nine different speed limits in that
short section of Highway it goes up and
down frequently um we asked uh we went
to some of the towns I met with several
of the towns along the corridor looking
to have a uniform 45 which I think means
that people aren't trying to guess what
the speed limit is they would know that
from Lebanon to clont it's 45 miles an
hour we didn't get broad support but I
think if there was that legislative
intent we could go back and revisit that
another location that's been on my radar
is one that was arbitrarily lowered in
the past is route 12 uh from Bath holl
to the West uh 302 and 10 to Woodstock
to the east um Lost River area has been
improved it's posted at 40 miles hour
but arguably that that stretch that
follows the AMC River of 112 is 35 for
that whole way and the only part that's
really condensed or warrants that lower
speed limit is a village of Swiftwater
with it posted 35 for that whole length
there's nothing that tells somebody
that's driving that and it's a scenic
route that gets a lot of tourist traffic
that you've reached this point where you
need to slow down so if that 120 was
posted at at 30 at 45 then we go back
let me stop on that so that 35 that
historically has been posted for Route
112 um this our regulation says that
it's because of the curval the KNE or
nature of the road but rather than
telling somebody at either end that you
should go 35 for the next 20
miles the better thing would be to give
them the speed limit that reflects the
the best you condition on the road and
then warn them for those curves and tell
them that the appropriate advisory speed
for those specific locations so like I
said it's not always about lowering the
speed limits like we've heard this
morning but it's giving us that
statutory value that we can go back and
look at some of these places that might
have been lowered in the past maybe
inappropriately or trying to to make a
more consistent uniform speed limit over
long segments rather than the patch work
that we have in a lot of places
today so like I said the purpose of this
bill and it and it comes from a lot of
the requests we get from towns uh to
look at speed limits and and when we do
this engineering and traffic
investigation which takes some time and
resources uh that those that data
doesn't support the lower speed limit or
change um but like I said when I started
speed limits in the state are determined
by this body so if this body determines
that the statutory value for those rural
two-lane roads is 45 and that's what the
dot should follow and exceptions from
that value should be an exception and
based on a pretty high bar of an
engineering and traffic investigation I
apologize for the length of the
testimony but I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you I've got I've got a
couple and I'm sure the hands will go up
if you don't mind while it's fresh
representative 112 if I can ask you on
112 if that's if that's considered a
rural High rate correct mhm why is it 35
mph from Woodstock to Swiftwater Village
I've looked at the regulation on that
and again it came from what folks and
Swift water wanted the lower speed limit
and the regulation um says it's due to
the curval linear nature of the road so
someone back in history in the
dot probably had some crashes in some of
those curves along the river and said
people should slow down so let's make it
35 um people aren't I just did the speed
report yesterday and um the 85th
percentile speed is close to 47 to 50
right a lot of those locations so it
would be more appropriate if it's the
curves that are the problem put curve
signs up and then tell people what the
measured advisory speed for that curve
is but but that's where I'm confused if
if you're saying that it's actually the
towns that have dictated that speed
limit at 35 because of the curvy nature
of the road even though most of the
curves are gone
now how is this going to change with
your authority to supersede the towns to
increase it to 45 from the 35
um to clarify the town's not responsible
for that 35 that would have been
somebody from the department and back in
the day it would would have been our
Highway Maintenance Engineers the
district Engineers that were determining
speed limits uh so the definition of a
engineering and traffic investigation
would probably Loosely interpreted to
somebody driving in best guess of what
that should be um this statutory 45
would give us the ability to to uh reach
out to a town of Hao or bath or um some
of the towns in between Benton and and
uh propose that we change the speed
limit and add the curve signs an example
would be uh and and we like you said we
don't have a proactive plan to address
all the roads in the state um but we can
be responsive uh the police chief in
Wakefield several years ago had asked us
to look at the speed limit on 153 that
was 35 and from his perspective he had a
hard time enforcing 35 because um if he
pulled somebody over at 45 to 50 he was
pulling them over at the prevailing
speed which he thought was reasonable
and safe if his officers were pulling
people over at 60 which he thought was
speeding now it's 25 over the speed
limit and it's a stiffer penalty and it
must appear in court so at his request
we looked at the speed limit we met with
the town and we raised the speed limit
to 45 but before we did that we measured
all the curves and we put I want to say
over 12 miles 200 curve assets which to
me is safer because we're telling people
why they should slow down and where and
to what value yeah and thank you for
that and know it's a follow up on the
same question so if it's actually the
department that created the 35 on 112
I'm not on 153 I'm back to
112 does the department have the ability
to revisit their own decisions if if you
say it was done 30 years ago um doesn't
the department have an opportunity now
under current Law Without this to
actually do what you propose because
some areas can support the 55 there with
the reduced in the corners if do you
have the ability now that's a great
question thank you for that question um
the statutes do allow the commissioner
of Transportation um to unilaterally set
speed limits um that's delegated to the
state traffic engineer I'm not a
masochist I'm not going to Interchange
signs unless I have got local support So
putting that in statute gives me
something that I can you I can bring to
the town and say that the legislative
intent is 45 and um I can be persuasive
I've I've raised more speed limits in
the last 15 years than I've lowered um
but I certainly understand that there
are places like a 102 in London Dair in
a group four Rollinsford where people
are driving just too fast so it kind of
addresses both of those conditions okay
and and again the commissioner does have
RSA
26562 uh it doesn't Define what an
engineering and traffic investigation is
it does require it um but the
commissioner does have that Authority
thank you I've got more but I'll share
um any other question questions from the
committee I saw representative
SES thank you Mr chairman Mr Lambert
welcome to the transportation committee
again um my question
is do we have actual crash fatality data
that is tied to the specific types of
roads that we are that are under
discussion
um I heard a lot about fatal crashes it
would be nice to have an actual hard
data point that would point to uh
that
information uh amander is our subject
matter expert I mean the crash data is
usually from the Department of Safety uh
we are customers of the crash data I
that our CR our crashes are um very
difficult to locate actually a a person
from DMV is at the room uh who's in the
room right now uh we work actively on
that um to try to identify that
um it's it's hard to pull out that
information I did do a uh crash study on
i93 where the uh speed limit was raised
from 65 to 70 and we were only really
able to locate it by town but
um and that's where it kind of stops um
unless we
actually get every crash report in the
state which we don't have access to
right now mostly because of uh
privacy personal identification
information um then we could do that but
that's it's a lot of work for the DMV
it's a lot of work for us so follow
up if I understand you correctly then my
question ought more properly be asked of
the
DMV to get that
data um I think the DMB and or the
office of Highway Safety both within the
department of safety okay I will ask
that question if I assume we're hearing
from DMV about this and if not I'll ask
the
question
okay representative a thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr Lambert for taking
my question um we've heard testimony
before that simply lowering a speed
limit doesn't
necessarily make people drive slower
that the conditions of the roads are
going to dictate what the speed limit is
without constant law enforcement
presence um if you do lower the speed
limit on like a 102 how is there a way
where do you have plans to add elements
to the roadway to cause create more
friction to slow traffic down
appropriately or is this just going to
be symbolic or just a tool for law
enforcement to be able to
use thank you for the question
representative that testimony was
probably from me um people have been in
this room for a while know that um I
have made that testimony that changing
the speed limit alone doesn't uh doesn't
change behavior however um changing the
speed limit to a consistent uniform
value um gives law enforcement a tool
that they can they can enforce town like
London der has pretty um robust uh
enforcement resources and they can also
reach out to the office of Highway
Safety they do do targeted enforcement
grants so um again if this if the
legislative intent for Rural highways is
45 M hour then that's what the speed
limit is unless Modified by an
engineering traffic
investigation um so I I I would say that
this is a matter of the statutory value
of the speed limit so it's what your
intent would be for Rural I'd say the
majority of highways in the state of New
Hampshire I've got to jump back in here
for a minute the legislative intent
right now is 55 miles an hour with the
Department of Transportation having the
authority to make changes and reduce it
where
needed so let's look at Albany that that
one raised a couple of eyebrows for me
they said it took an Act of God to get
the engineering and the information from
the dot when they requested their speed
limit to go down I don't know why it
would be a lengthy or drwn out process
and two they were
deny so if this passes I
guess why was it denied and and and then
therefore why would it should be 45 If
This Were to
pass that's a good question um in 201 22
when they petitioned a department for uh
speed limit reduction um the resources
that we had for getting speed data were
um cumbersome we'd have to send a crew
out with tubes or radar side um sidef
fired radar device or some device to
measure speeds at a point maybe several
points on a road like one or like
16 since that time we've got probe data
so we can get not every vehicle on the
road but there a pretty good percentage
of U pen ation of the vehicle so speed
data is a lot easier for us to get now
but the reason that it was denied is
because we're the statutory value is 55
because it doesn't meet one of the other
criteria and so it had to be based on
engineering and traffic investigation
and the 85th percentile speeds were in
the 55 to 60 range if I remember right I
didn't bring that speed study with me um
and and that's part of the criteria but
we also look at roadside hazards um
crash history and things like that we
use a a program that Federal Highway
produce called us limits 2 that that
takes all the data and then um runs
algorithms come up with a recommended
value and it supported the the
55 um if if this bill were to pass then
we can look at the context of the road
just like we would in a rural residence
District or a business district and say
this is an unimproved two-lane rural
45 I'm not trying to be a hog last one
for me it'll be a quick one
one that leads me to my last question
will this Bill affect route 102 because
every stretch of 102 that I know of is
improved this bill specifically calls
unimproved good question I think this
body has granted the authority to to
change um to interpret the statutes on
RSA 26562 to the commissioner of
transportation and as Senator Carson
test
commissioner Cass did indicate that 102
would fit the nature of this bill um I
would say that in the statutes the the
the definitions in chapter
259 uh if you read the definition of
urban residential rural rural
residential and business district it's
not necessarily clear um I would say
that the definition that I drafted for
the rural unimproved rural two-lane road
similarly unclear I think there's room
for interpretation and discretion um but
commissioner Cass has indicated that 102
description U let me go on the order I
found them thank you any other questions
committee okay repres Johnson
welcome thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr Lambert um my question regards to the
text of the language for the
um the text itself so when we've we've
inserted section D the new section D and
therefore all the subsequent lettered
sections should be uh shifted down by
one e becomes f f becomes G if you read
the new section e itself 55 miles per
hour in other locations except as
provided in E it hasn't been changed to
F so is that a is that a typo or is that
on purpose or that is an error thank you
for the thank
you further
questions representative
C thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question uh I was a little
concerned on section two uh adding the
description of an unimproved rural
highway but all of the it seemed like
all the U testimony we heard before you
um including 102 and
londondary uh that just doesn't sound to
me like it's unimproved roads so I'm
wondering whether this uh change would
affect those roads at all and did I just
would thank you for the question um I
think what what you heard me say was
that uh ultimately this authorities the
commissioner of transportation and
commissioner Cass has indicated in some
of these locations um because he gets
the calls all the time everybody wants
people to go slower uh 102 specifically
and I'm thinking route four in uh ra
it's New Hampshire 4 not us4 and
Rollinsford uh he agreed with as well U
both of those
locations uh I came up with the
definition uh because of those are the
kinds of roads that we get we get
complaints about a lot and and I
struggled with it
um it been vetted through some internal
resources my intent would be the 112s
and the the route 16s that that are
truly just paved versions of the
historic cart paths um but it's subject
to interpretation and I think the
commissioner U transportation has
indicated that a couple of those roads
would fit that I don't know if that's a
great answer um I I struggle with trying
to interpret all of the definitions in
259 in the statute and I probably added
just a fourth one that's going to add to
the
confusion represent of
SES thank you Mr chairman M uh Mr
Lambert um some of this uh research that
I've seen indicates that the 85th
percentile is problematic in so many
different ways and I wonder a where is
the statutory authority to use the 80 uh
is it 85 I think right 85 85th
percentile to determine speed limits
come from and and
secondarily um is there any effort on
the part of the department to take a
look at that and see if that should be
changed
great question appreciate the the
question
um the 85th percentile historically
comes from research that was done by
what's now Federal Highway in the 1960s
um by um an engineer named David Solomon
and the determination that if you looked
at the the 85th percentile if you looked
at the crash rate curve versus the speed
distribution curve that the 85th
percentile speed tended to be the lowest
point on the crash rate curve um there's
been a lot of dialogue about that ever
since then um a lot of the research
that's out there I think is somewhat
biased as the research that supports the
85th percentile people that do research
can can can bias it in a number of
different ways um I think the
current feel philosophy on the 85th
percentile on speed setting is that the
85th percentile is probably appropriate
for Rural highways um but that when
you're looking at urban areas then you
need to look more at context
um research that was done by Texas
Transportation Institute um not too long
ago that Federal highways using to
upgrade their their project is looking
at more like the 50th percentile um
there's about a 5 mph difference at most
at the higher speeds
um um we look at the data um right now
we're using the US limits too because
that's a tool that that's objective um
but it's only there's engineering
judgment involved as well but the 85th
percenti St is very controversial you
asked about where that is in statute
um it's based on that research from the
1960s but it lives in federal
regulations in the federal manual and
uniform traffic control devices which
says that speed limits that aren't
statuto uh that a based on engineering
and traffic investigation should be
percentile still have a
question oh what was represent
Jones Thank you Mr chair and thank you
both for being here um and if I Mr chair
if I may follow up on the question from
both you and representative c um do we
need that term unimproved in
things thank you for the question um I
would say that that my intent with that
was to be that cart path that was over
but um hearing testimony today and the
questions from this this committee
striking the term unapproved would
language that's represent
blonda thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here thank you for that
question because that was one of mine um
I just wanted to ask a couple questions
one is um in the areas where we're
looking been going from 35 to 45 a lot
of the roads have been mentioned are up
north my concern is during the winter
months do you foresee any flexibility
that during the winter months the dot
can lower the rates back to 35 or do you
feel there's any concern in during the
winter months and these speed
changes thank you for the question so
the the winter months during snowstorms
the statute uh to
26560 requires drivers to drive to
conditions so the winter months when the
when the pavement is icy or wet I think
that's already covered in statutes and
I'm not a believer that we should be
lowering speed limits for those
conditions that we need to hold drivers
somewhat accountable to understand what
the conditions are um I I don't think we
would raise any of those rural highways
to 45 if this passed unless we had local
support and part of that local support
would be a um we do the engineering
study to bring to a community but we
would take that recommendation to a
community before we'd make any changes
and some of the cases like I said in
Wakefield before we change the black and
white signs to to a higher value we want
to make sure we look at the engineering
to see if we need to put any additional
warning signs or change guard real
limits or or any of that type of thing I
hope that answered your question thank
you follow up Mr chair last one follow
up yep last one
um I've requested many traffic models uh
and n area and it was always in
conjunction with the regional Planning
Commission and
do my question is has there been any
feedback from uh Regional planning
commissions throughout New Hampshire on
of thank you for the question
um as we've reconstructed our highway
safety section and Amanda is part of
that process we've been revisit we've
been visiting with the regional planning
commissions uh throughout the state
we've hit all of a sudden Regional
planning commissions and part of our
update we talk about all the things that
we're working on and this this proposed
bill has been part of that discussion U
not getting any negative not getting any
feedback one way or the other getting
some head
nods thank you Mr
chair okay one last one for me and this
is why I'll be honest with everybody
I've never been a fan of these bills and
this is why 26560 is pretty simple no
person shall drive a vehicle on on away
at a speed greater than is reasonable
and prudent under the conditions and
having regard for the actual potential
hazards then existing in other words the
onus and the responsibility has always
been us on us as individuals the speed
limits we have are speed limits it
doesn't mean you have to go 55 if the
sign says it if there are people in the
street and so I see this and would you
agree that all passing this is going to
do is slow down traffic even even though
we a lot of us agree that it's probably
not going to make people drive slower uh
it's an effort in areas that even the
traffic studies don't
support such as
um I I think the easy answer for that is
that Commissioner of Transportation
struggles with responding to communities
that are looking for Speed um reduction
speed reductions and speed reduction is
not speed limit reduction that they just
want people going through slower a lot
of the the places that we get the calls
and complaints from are are places like
Albany where the state highway is the
main street um the commissioner has
struggle with being able to be um
responsive to those communities but
where they the statute and the
engineering and traffic investigation do
not support the change um am I going to
fix the world with this with this bill I
don't think so uh I I think it's um one
of one of the things we struggle with is
that there's a you heard the bill
earlyer of the session there's a there's
a culture that thinks that 10 miles an
hour over the speed limit is the speed
limit that it's not the number on the
sign it's that plus 10 and this is an
attempt to get that culture to
understand that less than the speed the
speed limit is a maximum value it's not
a minimum value I I did have um a prop
that I was going to bring in today it's
a there was a place in 135 in I think
bath but north of Woodsville where
previous commissioner had been armed
Twisted to lower the speed limit to 30
for an agricultural property well
outside the village of Woodsville and um
we put the sign up and the chief was
enforcing it and then it had to be
replaced three or four times because of
all the shotgun shells that went through
it thought the last one that my sign
foran replaced had a note in the back
that said please don't shoot me so speed
limit
speed limits are pretty sensitive for
the drivers in public and they're
sensitive for the people that live near
the roads as
well thank you for your time thank you
very much um I should have given this
one a couple hours I could keep going
but uh without seeing anybody else uh or
having anybody else signed up I'm going
to close the public hearing on Senate
Bill
471 and we are running behind that is
why I built in this time I kind of had a
feeling uh just a minute to reset we'll
go into Senate Bill 581
and representative Waters is probably
okay be uh be at 11:29 I'm going to open
up the public hearing on SB 469 relative
to allowing surveillance of a park and
ride facility in certain
circumstances um chair Rec uh recognizes
Senator David Waters welcome back
Senator thank you very much uh Mr
chairman Senator David Waters District 4
introducing Senate Bill
469 relative to allowing surveillance to
the park ride facility in certain uh
circumstances this bill is a request of
of the department um trying to uh amend
our existing statute on surveillance um
uh that of entities that at least or
otherwise operate on behalf of the
department which means your Park and
Ride um facilities now I will back up
just a moment to talk about it
surveillance in general I've worked for
many many years with representative Kirk
on privacy and surveillance issues
because we know how Bedrock important
that is um what we are in a situation um
now is that private businesses that have
a parking lot can have that kind of
surveillance of it and what what uh this
bill aims to do is to let private
entities I'll mention C&J Bus Lines
because they're in in my area and uh you
all know Jim jalbert from the
Transportation Council um that's his
company and uh so in and over or down in
Portsmouth or down in Seabrook now but
it's not just him it's others who do the
leasing of the park and ride um
facilities uh right now because we don't
have this um opportunity in in statute
um they can't use the possibility of
surveillance to keep customers safe and
their property safe what we' and I think
they should I mean I I I I think that
they really should it's so the people
who use those Park and Ride facilities
want to get in a bus and come back and
have their car um be safe what we have
built into this statute are the kind of
appropriate privacy
protections how long can one of these
surveillance tapes be kept now if you're
a private business you can keep it about
forever if you want but it's important
to have restrictions on that and then
who would have access to it important to
have restri restrictions on that as well
what the bill would allow is a police
department to go to the operator of the
of the lot and to have access if there's
a criminal Cain now what would have to
happen is they have to go through the
department and then go through through
the department through the operator to
the police
department um so that seems like an
unnecessary
cumbersome uh procedure we have folks
here from uh do who can talk a lot more
about the particular samples but I think
it's a a reasonable accommodation for
our concerns about uh privacy and
surveillance uh that if you are a
private entity there's leasing a lot and
you could do this anyways if it was your
own lot but because you're leased you
can't I think we ought to have some
common sense accommodation and thank you
Mr chairman and I am expected back in my
hearing so i' be glad if there is a
question for me but I if you wouldn't
mind going to the do folks
okay you have one quick
question representative Hill uh could
you speak to the Constitutional
Amendment we recently passed that said
an individual's right to live free from
government intrusion and private or
personal information is natural
essential and inherent I'm concerned
about the storage part of
this bill yeah uh thanks for the
question um you know it's interesting
because in fact this is not a you know
it's a leased facility and so business
operating a parking lot now that
constitutional provision would not would
not apply um it I do think that this
would be
permissible um given the restraints that
are in here it is only for law
enforcement purposes that that tape can
be accessed because there has been a
criminal activity there's been potential
potentially Criminal activ
reported so I I my I mean not being a
constitutional lawyer but I I do think
that the uh protection of Provisions
here for this these circumstances would
not um come into conflict with that
constitutional
provision thank you thank you
Senator chair and I would like to
recognize Shelley
Winters who is in support of the bill
representing the New Hampshire deal
requesting five minutes
welcome thank you and for the record my
name is Shelley Winters I'm the director
of Aeronautics Rail and Transit at the
Department of Transportation and as
Senator water said the department is in
favor of this and requested this um what
we're looking to do is basically restore
provide the rights of private businesses
that are entering into agreements with
the state um we don't feel like they
should be penalized for entering to an
agreements with the state and standing
in the shoes to help facilitate safe
passenger transportation and in this
case we're mostly talking about uh bus
companies that are managing the the nine
up to nine state owned parking ride lots
and bus terminals that have a heavy
Transit presence we're talking about
hundreds and thousands of New Hampshire
residents going through on a regular
basis we're talking about people leaving
their personal vehicles there we're
talking about people um dropping off
their daughters their wives um leaving
their vehicles there so what we're
looking to do is basically allow them to
to follow industry standards similar to
how um the airline industry and and TSA
and airports are now um having you know
a safe security system and and doing it
on a parallel with each other we're
looking to to allow that to happen on
state owned facilities that are managed
by private entities mostly bus companies
to allow comparability of the security
systems there so it would be expanding
to Industry standard um the archival
video footage that is retained it would
be allowing law enforcement direct
access to those images on site instead
of going through the department and
three or four signatures in multiple
days to be able to access that footage
should something um time sensive or
nefarious uh were to occur and it would
allow live viewing by local police
departments on site working with those
contracted facility operators who manage
our facility so um again unfortunately
things occur in these Park and Ride Lots
we wish they wouldn't um we see that's
you know pervasive everywhere right now
so again this is just for security to
allow um safety of the state
infrastructure safety of the passengers
using these Terminals and leaving their
personal vehicles and belongings there
and the bus terminal staff themselves
and we feel that this will streamline
the process to make it quicker easier
for law enforcement as well as the
facility operators and bring a
comparable Lev level of security to the
industry um that these bus operators use
at their own personal facilities that
they own that they privately own or as
they operate in other states and as we
talk with our counterparts nationally um
so again with that I'm happy to to
answer questions that you may have and
again it would just apply to the nine
listed facilities we aren't asking it to
expand to you know 26 or 30 or any in
all of the park and ride Lots it's just
applies to those that would have um
scheduled bus services and that are
statute thank you so much any questions
from the committee representative St
Clair thank you Mr chair thank you um
does the railroad station in
Dover have is that covered by this now
or do they do you know how that works
there I'm unsure of the the Amtrak down
Easter stations I know on the UNH campus
they do have security cameras they are
not subject under the same statute those
are not state owned facilities that were
privately owned by um used to be PanAm
by CSX and those host communities lease
space from them so I'm not sure where
they fall my guess is that they fall
under much like a private business and
entity and would not be subject um to
the limitations that that this is
talking about right thank you
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um it's really a two question
how long is this is the are the items
being stored um and the second part is
you're only asking for
um the the surveillance for those nine I
think you mentioned what prevents the
others currently from being uh
surveilled so for the two-part question
the first question is um under statute
24 days is the limitation in in current
statute that the images can be retained
for unless they were requested under a
legal Authority and then there's a
longer thing because it could be held up
for a court case so 24 days right now is
the current under statute um and what's
to stop any of the other Park and Ride
Lots from having cameras I'd have to dig
into the current RSA we looked for the
exemption or the inclusion of those nine
locations because they had terminals
with more um State more expensive State
infrastructure and there was a higher
presence of of public going through
there so I would have to um look into
that about adding adding more if they
representative
Sykes thank you Mr chairman uh Miss
Winters
um I'm trying to remember it seems to me
that a bill passed through the house and
was signed that would allow for the type
of surveillance you're asking about at
the park and ride in New London correct
why is why is that the tool that allowed
that to happen however that happened
not sufficient as opposed to a separate
wholly separate
bill right you are correct so New London
was was one of the ones added is in the
listed um the nine Lots in there the
department right now is in a position we
are not directly uh we don't have the
staff to directly manage and facilitate
the transportation services out of these
locations including New London so we
have long-term agreements leases or
other agreements with private entities
that are standing in the state's shoes
to operate manage and maintain and so
we're looking to allow that
comparability to Industry standard um
you know vehicles are allowed to park up
to 21 days when you have a 24 day
restriction on the video images by the
time somebody comes back they get a late
flight they may actually you know be
there longer than 24 days or they don't
realize something is is missing or
something occurred um the retention
period really doesn't allow one to go
back to try to identify the root cause
but I I think repes to your your
question it's the state has someone else
standing in our shoes who um is looking
to do this business and do it comparably
to Industry standards so that's that's
what we didn't contemplate back when we
added New London and these other listed
locations is we didn't look at the
long-term implications of the facility
operators I actually have a question for
you uh allowing surveillance are we
talking cameras are we talking you know
police you know security cars kind of
going up and down the roads of these
Park Lots is it both I mean what what's
surveillance are we talking so we're
talking security I know the wording in
the RSA says surveillance but these are
we're really talking about security
camera system so um allowing a different
software type a different uh app that
can be viewed by the facility operators
so um you know most of them do not have
security firms or staff that are driving
vehicles around they're really relying
on the technology to to be that security
presence to try to um you know follow up
on anything that were to
occur any other questions with committee
representative plon thank you Mr chair
just a quick question I just want to be
clear it sounds like the installation
and the management of the the
surveillance equipment would be by the
state not the the private entity bus
companies is is not that accurate So
currently right now all of the camera
security systems that are in there were
purchased installed and implemented by
the the department and managed or viewed
on a daily basis by the facility
operators this change would allow under
a long-term leas agreement for the
facility operator as the cameras become
Antiquated security no longer you know
patches don't support it would allow the
facility operator to act more quickly
than the department going out to bid
going to a state contract going you know
taking six to 6 months to 3 years to
replace a system it would allow them to
quickly replace it to comparable
standards and then manage it accordingly
retain it um as they see fit and to work
locally with law enforcement so just a
quick follow up followup um where the
legislation is currently written and it
ident you stated it identifies only the
nine
facilities would it take additional
legislation to cover the other Park and
rides in the state where we do have
vandalism and a series of other uh
you know class A felonies going on uh
would you do you think we would need
additional legislation or would this
future I'm looking at uh Kathy M who's
who's an attorney I'm not an attorney
and not going to play with today I we I
would have to as the question was asked
before I'd have to go back and and look
at that this would be laying a couple a
couple exemptions within 236 130 so I'd
have to see how how they would lay in
layer I can't say right right now we do
not have any security cameras in any of
the Lots other than those that are
currently listed um in paragraph
uh under G1 so G1 through um nine are
the only locations of state owned Park
and Ride lots that we have cameras in so
there are in none of the others and I I
would have to again look into
this okay thank you thank you Mr chair
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman um currently we're talking
about cameras um is there anything in
this legislation that would preclude
additional surveillance items I'm
thinking if somewhere along the line
someone wanted to install uh plate
readers or something like that would
that would that be um possible or is
that is it strictly cameras at this
point it dist strictly cameras so
additional follow up additional
types of
surveillance couldn't be added without
coming back to us and modifying the
RSA I think the RSA as it exists 236 130
paragraph one defines surveillance and I
think that's probably addressed in here
again not an attorney we can go back and
confer on on that but rules or something
like that though surveillance not that
I'm aware of it's surveillance means
cameras
surveillances for Highway surveillances
as defined in 236 130 um Roman numeral
one so I don't think we intended to
change that at all we're just intending
to to add on this new sub paragraph
thank
you you also were mentioning uh you were
looking at a piece of paper about letter
g with some things listed and I see a
lot of of people in the committee kind
of looking for that can you make sure
that we get a copy yeah it's just
actually it's 2:30 it's the it's the
current RSA it's 236 uh 130 so I was
just making sure I cited the right
letter any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much thank you for your time and with
that I don't have any cards uh anybodys
to testify so at this moment I'm going
to close the testimony and the hearing
on SP
thought said five 58 he said 56
okay being 11:47 we'll open up the
public hearing on Senate Bill 581
relative to temporary driver's licenses
and non-driver identification cards uh
da fette Dy
fette on behalf of Senator
Rashard this is my last one for the day
I promise how you how you like your time
and transportation today it's been great
I've actually never testified in front
of this committee before
so so good morning again Mr chair and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Daley Fett and I'm the Senate
majority caucus director and I'm here
this morning to introduce Senate Bill
581 on behalf of Senator rardy Senate
Bill 581 allows for the issuance of a
temporary proof of license license or
non-driver identification upon
expiration of a valid driver driver's
license or non-driver identification
card the DMV has issued temporary
credentials at the counter for several
years for every type of Licensing or
identification card transaction your
permanent credential is then mailed to
the mailing address you have on file
with the
Department in addition the DMV
implemented an online renewal process
which allows a New Hampshire resident to
renew their license or ID card online
every other 5-year cycle with a special
Rin number
that is mailed to them 90 to 120 days
prior to the renewal date while the
temporary credentials issued at the
counter have the appearance of an actual
license printed on paper and is
recognized as a valid license to drive
the ones issued when you renew online
are only considered a temporary proof of
license the print out provided is only a
receipt with the application's name
license number issue date expiration
date and expiration date of their
previous license I should say uh CL of
license and any endorsements or
restrictions it does not have a photo
address or any demographic information
listed the intent of this temporary
proof was that it would be used in Con
in conjunction with their current or
previous license or ID until they obtain
the permanent one and this is stated at
the bottom of the print out they
receive under new Administration it was
recognized that this temporary proof of
license process is not defined in
statute the DMV believes this process to
be uh beneficial to the residents of the
state and once formalized process and
statute so the citizens of New Hampshire
as well as law enforcement understand
how this temporary proof of license
intended to be used and accepted thank
you for allowing me the opportunity to
speak today uh Senator Chari thanks you
for your consideration and if you have
any questions I can take them to the
senator but I also believe there's
someone from DMV here who would be able
to better answer those
questions thank you thank you and for
the committee uh Department of Motor
Vehicles is signed up to speak next so
any questions from the committee seeing
none thank you very much thank you very
much next up chair recognizes Jenifer
Bailey from the Department of Motor
bill still good morning uh my name is
Jennifer Bailey I'm the administrator of
Department of Motor Vehicles um so yes
we are in support we requested this bill
as stated another cleanup Bill where we
realized that the although we do have
authority to issue temporary license in
the statute currently that tempor
license wasn't defined um so this bill
is putting in several one to define the
temporary license as an actual license
um as well as add in what that temporary
proof when you renew online is able to
be used as um there's not much more he
did a great introduction I'm open for
any questions that you might may have
about the on the
process thank you um have we always had
temporary licenses or is this just an
advent of more technology because I
remember when they used to heat seal it
after they took your picture your left
there with your permanent license yep um
so I that's when I first started working
there we were doing that we have been
doing temporary licenses for I would say
I think we're at like 13 to 14 years now
so it was with a new contract we got all
new equipment and that's when we
implemented the temporary licenses we
were I believe the 30th state to
implement that most States now follow
that temporary license first process
right so this is self-inflicted any
questions from the
committee representative Hill thank Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question can you please um explain to me
well the the differences or or how the
temporary license differs visually from
another license specifically for this
identification for any legal purpose
except voting section of the of the bill
sure thank you for the question so when
you renew in person you are issued a
temporary license that looks just like
your primary hard copy license it has
your image on it your signature your
credential it's it's an actual physical
copy of your license just in paper black
and white form that's why for that
purpose of over the counter temporary
we're saying that you're able to use
that as proof of drive and for
identification because it has all your
demographics all of your information on
it when you renew online due to privacy
and that we don't have a portal where
you're logging into your account you're
using a ren number to Access that and
we're issuing that based off the
information we have in our system um
you're only receiving a receipt that
tells you that you have renewed online
it lists your class and your
endorsements and a temporary expiration
date but there is no image or anything
to attach that to your license so in
that case we're asking that you use that
in conjunction
with your current or previous license
that you have on hand so you have a
picture photo ID and this temporary
receipt is just an act that you have
extended your license and we waiting for
one anybody else from the
committee I knew it representative
P just got my there we go just got my
temporary and I just for the record want
to make it clear
that to any in order to to renew a
license if there's any changes on your
existing license you cannot renew online
you have to go to a DMV and get one of
these With The Changes wait for the new
one so just just for clarification there
are restrictions that's uh on getting
renewals it's only if there's no changes
correct you are able to change your
height and weight um in eye color and
hair color but you're not able to update
your address you're not able to change
your um restrictions or endorsements we
mail it to the add address that we
currently have on file for you I changed
my
height I got one one more question
um since we've been using the temporary
licenses especially the copy ones with
the picture and all that have there ever
been any cases of fraud making their own
copies not that I'm aware of um we are
right now you're not holding the
temporary for that long um we are
mailing on a I believe we're at seven
days right now so we
do advertise that you're receiving it
within 60 days but we are able to
produce a license within we're at seven
business days right now so you're
getting your license fairly
quickly yeah well anything it only takes
a moment but uh thank you I'll look into
it else anybody else from the committee
see you none thank you very much thank
you I have nobody else signed up to
speak on Senate Bill 581 so I'm going to
close the public
hearing and it was looking scary for a
little bit but 11:55 not bad I'm getting
good at this stuff or
lucky yep um so we'll take a break for
lunch um we've got two more bills to
hear this afternoon I assume we'll
probably have a little caucus time and
um then going to Executive session and I
have requested of the ranking member uh
when I did our schedule just so you all
know why they're not there I was just in
haste and I didn't think to put down the
four bills that we heard three weeks ago
as poss believe being exact so uh we may
take those up as well if we come to an
agreement yeah and a time and the time
uh that's why I did put these last two
in the afternoon just in case they do
run over so uh but if we could chip away
at some of the ones we don't have to
stare at 10 executive sessions on our
last day that would be helpful for all
bit
e
okay good afternoon sorry for the delay
uh being 1114 I'm going to open up the
public hearing on Senate Bill 501
relative to driver's licenses for
non-citizens residing in New Hampshire
chair recognizes the prime spons
Senator Benton welcome back to
Transportation thank you for having me
happy to be home good morning Mr chair
or afternoon I should say Mr chair and
members of the committee for the record
I am Senator Donovan Fenton I represent
district 10 I'm here to introduce Senate
Bill 501 relative to driver's licenses
for non-citizens R residing in New
Hampshire the proposed amendments to RSA
263 39a in this bill provide further
Clarity to the issue of driver's license
eligibility for noncitizen residents of
New Hampshire this bill does not add or
expand classes of immigrants eligible
for New Hampshire driver's license I
want to be very clear about that this
bill is simplifying simply clarifying
language that the DMV already does it is
consistent with the Hampshire's DMV's
historic and current interpretation and
administration of driver's licensing
statutes and administrative rules it
states with Clarity the classes of
non-citizens who are currently applying
for New Hampshire driver's license in
most cases the New Hampshire gmv
conditions the issuance of a New
Hampshire driver license on a
non-citizen authorization to work in the
US any non-citizen authorized to work in
the US will possess a social security
number which is also required in most
cases to obtain a New Hampshire driver's
license and a big reason for this bill
was that I had a uh constituent in uh
district 10 who was the overnight
janitor at our Hospital a job very
difficult to fill and um they had
trouble getting their driver's license
due to uh the language not being clear
and this individual had time Hard Times
getting to the job because of so
snowstorm rain and and these are jobs we
need to fill an amendment was requested
by the DMV uh that adopted to remove the
requirement of proof of vehicle
operation in a foreign country for
temporary non-citizen drivers
license and essentially you know this
bill memorizes the process that the DMV
currently utilizes and uh paves away for
law to align with the rule change that
was made and to sum it all up folks you
know we had 47,000 job openings last
year in April it' be really nice to fill
this um there's not a lot of public
transportation in my neck of the woods
and especially a lot of rural areas and
uh clarifying this language will help
you get their driver's licenses and get
them to jobs um you know I have a family
business and I have 10 job openings at
the moment and one of the main questions
I ask is do you have reliable
transportation and I own a car business
which is kind of a weird question to ask
somebody when I'm trying to get hire
them but a lot of these individuals
there's no public transportation so uh
this is really a Workforce Bill and with
that I'm happy to take any questions you
may
have thank you any questions from the
committee representative Hill thank you
Mr chairman thank you Senator uh welcome
again back here um I'm wondering if you
can explain to me uh the cross out of
non-resident alien and inserting
non-citizen thank you for the question
representative I think there's um an
effort to
reclassify uh uh these individuals
coming to country as non-citizens
instead of aliens um so I think that's
just updating language
um
essentially from from the language is
being updated from
where it's changing aliens to
non-citizens because we're talking about
individuals who have work permits that
are working here're they're not aliens
they're non-citizens who are able to
work
here thank you any other questions OB C
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um is there any way
on here to prevent these people who are
not citizens from voting using this ID
card as a voter so voting uh carries a
very heavy um retribution if they vote
with this they're they don't get their
driver's license they're they're they're
kicked out of the country it's uh this
this this bill which passed unanimously
through the Senate I might add um we
worked on it um that doesn't have
anything to do with voting it has to do
with individuals who are uh legally
allowed to work here obtaining a
driver's
license yeah go ahead follow
up u in New Hampshire a driver's license
even even if it's not New Hampshire
driver's license but a driver's license
is valid ID for voting and that's that's
my concern
there thank you for the question you
know um
you know we have individuals who are
non-citizens with work permits who have
driver's licenses already and we are
currently already doing this it's just
clarifying the language to the DMV so
that we can help these individuals get
to their
jobs for the questions well it's
interesting that you bring that up let
me ask the first question line
five uh who has been granted permanent
residence that's already in law and
somebody given permanent res residents
can already get an HED driver's license
they have all their information can you
give me some examples of
conditional you know you might it's a
good question Mr chairman um I do
believe someone from the DMV is here and
they can
uh probably Define that a little better
than I
could okay one other question for me um
people who are currently waiting for
their Asylum hearing or Asylum um
decision
um can they get in other words they're
still pending they're
they're can they get work authorizations
not not that I understand now okay
that's not what I've been told but thank
you any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you I'm gon to zip to my
committee now so thank you all so much
thank
Wellington
58 uh chair recognizes Christine
Wellington representing herself in
bill
welcome good afternoon thank you uh
chairman Walsh and uh members of the
committee for allowing uh me to speak I
am Christine Wellington I'm a uh
resident of Derry New Hampshire and I'm
also a member of the New Hampshire
immigrants rights Network uh my
colleague Ava uh Castillo from the New
Hampshire immigrant and right Alliance
for immigrants and refugees is also here
with me to just briefly U follow up on
um Senator Fenton's remarks um so one
thing I just want to make clear is that
this this bill pertains to non-citizens
who are lawfully present I.E that the US
government has given them U permission
to be here whether it's permanently or
temporarily uh temporarily that's
based on their particular status at the
time um the uh non-citizens usage uh one
of the reasons that the language appears
in the bill is because that is the
terminology that the DMV uses in their
regulations and we thought that the um
using the the same language would make
it less confusing that's really the
intention of the bill in my opinion to
um site um language that's found in
other parts of the um uh chapter 263 to
be um in one location so it reduces
confusion people can go and see who can
get a driver's license it doesn't change
anything it only um situates um the
language in one location um I just want
to uh mention briefly about uh concerns
about voter fraud this comes up um all
the time um as Senator Senator Fenton
pointed out
um there's already mechanisms in place
you have to be a US citizen you have to
be a certain age and you have to be a
resident of the town where you're
registering I am not an expert on uh
voter law but my understanding is if
somebody doesn't have um proof of
citizenship there they you're signing an
affidavit when I moved to New Hampshire
we registered at the clerk's office and
I had to get my a long form birth
certificate to prove that I was eligible
to register to vote so I think new Hamp
has um mechanisms in place I also want
to point out that voter fraud just
generally is throughout the United
States is not a huge issue and there was
a Heritage Foundation study I believe it
was that looked at voter fraud New
Hampshire and other states uh New
Hampshire for a period of over 10 years
had only
22 um incidents of voter fraud that was
caught and none of them appeared to be
people who were non-citizens they were
people that um got caught voting in the
wrong jurisdiction or something else so
this does not appear to be a major issue
either in the United States or in our
own State um the DMV and we do have a
DMV representative here today is really
on top of um identity fraud and they
have put mechanisms in place um one of
the mechanisms that refers to
non-citizens is a save program which DMV
employees utilize to verify somebody's
lawful presence within the United States
or citizenship within the United States
um people also bring up sometimes worry
about access to benefits to which the
person might not be eligible for that
also I I I have confidence having worked
in legal services for most of my career
here in New Hampshire that our state
agencies have mechanisms in place to
establish um eligibility uh and and have
Protections in place so that's really um
my comments um to add on to Senator
Fenton and um my colleague Eva and and
as a as a US citizen by choice I can
tell you there are plenty of people
excuse me can I get you to state your
name for the Castillo I live in
Manchester
uh I worked in every single election
before I became a citizen but motivating
people to to vote and if you see you
look at uh the secretary of state has a
a nice video uh of about legal permanent
residents and welcoming new citizens and
I'm featuring that people can live here
as legal permanent residens without
becoming citizens they have no right to
vote and I have never heard anybody uh
voting taking that because that could
really cost you a lot so people are not
you know they're legally here they're
legally driving here with drivers
licenses people do not go to vote if
they do not have the right to vote so
the the T the voting places are very
well educated uh in that sense and they
make sure that nobody that's not
supposed to vote uh does that this is a
non-nonsense bill really it's not adding
anything other than putting everything
together in one place you know if you
have an employment authorization you're
Dy qu legal in this country regardless
of what type of uh stat you have if
you're legally in the country and the
lady from the DMV can tell you exactly
where it is you're going to be able to
drive that's all you know in New
Hampshire we're safer and we're better
when people
drive according to the laws and the
rules and we need to drive to go to work
and to go to school and to go everything
because we do not have a good
transportation system so this bill
doesn't really add any extra benefit and
as far as benefit talking about that if
you don't have a valid social security
number you do not qualify for anything
and even the people that are here as
legal permanent residents that have
their social security numbers for the
first five years of becoming uh legal
permanent residents they do not qualify
for benefits from welfare for Medicaid
for anything so they there are tons of
mechanisms to for for that so there's no
reason to to fear anything uh with this
bill that really doesn't have much uh
other than simplifying
things thank you any questions from the
committee oh um yes I will need you to
fill out one of these pink cards too I
didn't know you were going to be t i you
can do it after the fact okay may
represent thank you Mr
chairman
um neither of you ladies may be the
right person to ask this question but
I'll put it out there now so that the
person or persons who can answer it can
answer it for me um my understanding is
that is is my understanding correct that
if a person has a nonresident driver's
license who is not a citizen who then
tries to vote and is caught they then in
fact would lose their status as being
able to continue their residence in this
country yes that is correct that that's
a very good point Thank You
representative Sykes um in immigration
law if you are caught representing
yourself as a citizen a US citizen in
any um scenario that triggers what they
call a permanent bar uh which would
uh trigger um a removal process um from
this country um it's it's one of the
biggest known knows I think the other
permanent bar is if you belong to the
Nazi party that's right which dates back
to like the 1930s so that that's a very
good point to make it it it is a
catastrophic thing to do to represent
whether in a voting situation or in any
other situation that you are US citizen
if you are
not thank you in fact that's one of the
questions they ask you when you put your
citizenship application and they go you
go to the interview they ask have you
ever claimed to be are you a citizen in
anything thank you um I've heard I have
one I've heard a few times uh the term
lawfully present does it say this
anywhere in the bill excuse me does it
say the words lawful presence or
lawfully present anywhere in the bill in
the bill no because this bill doesn't
change the um the statutes that are
already in existence it's just uh puts
all the information into 26 6
339a
um D and I think the DMV person uh could
probably uh answer this better but um
that's that's a baseline that you have
to prove that you have the permission of
the US government to be here to get a
New Hampshire driver's license so you
have to have certain us-based documents
you you're going to also use your your
foreign birth certificate or your pass
Port from your home country if you're
not a US citizen but you also have to
show us issued immigration status
documents and per permission to work and
the social security number that's US
government
based um just a
followup do you know and I'll ask this
now and we might get in I'll ask it
again who the federal government grants
lawful presence
to that is a question that would have to
do as an immigration law 101 if there
there's numerous numerous statuses some
are statuses that will eventually lead
somebody to be able to um apply for US
citizenship some like the original
language in 239 uh 263 39a refer to
people that are here on temporary work
visas by studying uh within the United
States um there's other kinds of visas
people I had a client when I did
immigration law work that came over here
on an entertainment visa she was a an
artist um a Music musician and she was
part of a a tour that came here and so
you have a there's all kinds of visas
have priests that have Visa that
religious religious Visa so there's
multiple categories of people I myself
was a a student on an F1 Visa an
international student for 15 years and
as long as I attended College fulltime I
had my Visa and I was perfectly legal in
the
country any other questions from the
committee representative
Hill thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um you mentioned uh
the people that um are are listed as
here lawfully um may have shown up with
um their um passport from a prior
country or Andor um other identification
documents if they have none are they
able to still um arrive here I was ref
and be law lawfully present excuse me I
I I'm sorry for interrupting you um I
was referring to what a non-citizen
would have to show to the DMV to to um
to um establish that they were eligible
for a license before you come over or if
you apply here you those two scenarios
both happen people apply from outside
the United States and get permission
some people apply with from within the
United States um it it's an extremely
complicated process uh no matter what
but you have to show documents um to be
given permission um they they always
involve um birth certificates and
passports uh and other documents that
might be relevant depending on what kind
of immigration benefit you're
seeking followup followup thank you if
you arrive here um with no
documentation are you able to be legally
present um there are many folks that
arrive here without documentation that
may never be able to secure a pathway to
lawful presence if you arrive here
without permission of the US government
and you um
seek Asylum you may be able to um stay
in the United States that's a a long
drawn out process where you have to
first establish with an immigration
officer that you you have articulated a
credible fear of being harmed or
tortured when you go back to your
country um so there's some people that
may be here while they're that the
government giv gives them permission you
may wait here while we're figuring out
your case um as cases the vast majority
of Asylum cases are denied in the end um
because it's a very high bar to show
that you are in particular danger people
from C certain countries um that are
experiencing uh war or um severe
disasters um may be given uh temporary
protected status for instance that that
may um you know be for a period of time
that the government May renew or they
say well the country is back to normal
we're not going to allow that status
anymore so it's just so complicated and
you have to be sort of an expert on
these different areas so even in
immigration law usually folks
concentrate on you know certain aspects
of it because it's it's very difficult
to cover the whole realm of that that
area
law but there are some people that will
never be able to get um status in the a
lawful status in the United States at
this point in time yeah any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you next up chair recognizes Jennifer
Vehicles good afternoon my name's
Jennifer Bailey again I'm here for the
DMV um we are in support of this bill um
a lot to unpack here but let me start
with the bill itself first um so the
first part of the bill before amendments
is just clarifying what we already do um
what this is adding is in our current
laws under 263 we consider permanent
residents similar to US citizens so
their authorization to get licenses was
in that law Senator Fenton is just
adding them into the non- US citizen
bill as a whole so this is not changing
anything as to what we're currently
issuing or how we're currently issuing
the amendment
was
originally um SB Bill 568 from Senator
richardi that we were requiring removing
the requirement for driver education and
Proof of Your Home Country license we
worked last summer and eliminated that
from from our administrative Rule and
this was a cleanup to remove that from
there since both bills were addressing
the same RSA they combined them um
instead of having two separate so that
is that part of things um for
several of the questions coming
up and I may not catch all of them so
you can Reas them the conditional or
permanent status so when you are a
permanent resident you may not
physically get your hard copy card
originally they will put a stamp it's
called an i51 stamp in your passport
that is your conditional it's usually
valid for one year until while you're
waiting for your actual card to come in
so that's what that intent by IAL
see I've testified in here before on the
asy refugee um lawful presence before
and I've tried afterwards to try to get
it into my head to kind of clarify it as
best I can and the most I can clarify it
is there are
three sets of presence in the United
States you're a US citizen you're
permanently here a permanent resident or
you are temporarily here permanent
resident includes permanent resident
cards Ayes refugees temporary residents
are going to be any visas as they
explained work visas um employment visas
work employment cards that are only
valid for one year to five years
depending on what they're being allowed
here to
do you can come here as a temporary
resident as a student and be here
legally
get a license under your student
visa while you're here you now feel
unsafe to return to your home country
you can apply for Asylum status that is
going from a temporary status to a
permanent status in the United States
which is why it takes so long and that's
where that lawfully present is because
they are legally here either under a
Visa or a work employment card so
they're eligible to have A license they
have a Social Security card but now
they're seeking permanent residents here
due to something happening in their home
country that's where that lawful
presence comes about um as they
explained if you come here with no
documents you are not getting a license
in New Hampshire you have to present
several documents your home country
passport because it will have your Visa
in it it may have a stamp in it as well
if you're here for duration of stay for
your education you'll also have
additional documents from immigration
for what college you're enrolled in or
what um agency you're working for that
you're providing and then your social
security card or a denial letter from
the Social Security office for example
as a student you're not eligible to work
in the US so you're not eligible for a
social security card they're going to
give you a letter stating
that um I believe I covered some of the
questions if I missed any of them please
feel free to ask me again but that is
all that I have for you guys today
thank you and I just want to clarify a
couple things I'm sure we'll have a few
questions not to throw anybody out of
the bus but when we were going through
are these are similar bills last year
the house bills I Time and Time asked
the director of Motor Vehicles how the
whole process works and he told me that
anybody that comes across the border
through a Port of Entry anybody
everybody who claims Asylum is given or
granted lawful presence that's what I
was told
over and over you're telling me that's
not the case not always the case no not
always the case not always the but
sometimes the case sometime it's not you
saying automatically granted lawful if
if they provide a name and it goes into
the save database and they're given an
asylum hearing or date they were granted
lawful presence to enter the country
that's what I've been told over and over
by the department not that I'm aware
there they have to apply with the with
immigration for that status
um and then again while that's pending
they may be granted lawful presence or
they may go through sending them right
back and that's only if they're coming
over with no no documents right so so I
I still need to verify that information
with with u immigration I'm not saying
it's the Department of Motor Vehicles
I'm just telling you what I was told the
last time we've heard these bills now
let's look at while somebody's here with
an asylum claim yes I was also told that
we were not giving drivers like is to
anybody with pending claims over and
over correct then I find out at the last
hearing that oh well no if they get a
temporary work authorization then we
will give them a driver's license
because that comes with a social
security number correct because they are
they have a work employment card that
may have been how they were originally
here they came here as a work employment
card while they're here because a work
employment card only allows them to stay
usually it's a one-year
period so then while they're here they
now feel unsafe to return home so
they're going to immigration and
applying for Asylum status to stay in
the US permanently and now that status
is pending but they're still they were
still legally here as to work on a work
employment cart we're talking about two
different groups of people we're talking
about the people that came here with a
Visa and the people that came here with
no documentation any other questions
from the committee represent
C uh thank you for
um um
anyone any non-citizen who gets a
driver's license what is the address
that gets printed on that driver's
license they have to have a New
Hampshire residence
address okay and they're showing proof
of residency follow up yeah follow uh
that's that's where I get concerned
about people being able to go vote
because it has a New Hampshire address
on it so if it says they have an address
here in conquered they can go to a
conquered word whatever and and vote um
I was wondering whether it would have
their original home address in whatever
country they came
from no new Hamp we actually have
statute that you have your license and
only have your New Hampshire license on
it anyways um but no they don't we don't
even look for their home country address
most of them are here for several years
so they're providing utility bills they
have lease agreements they're renting
someplace or they're owning a home um
staying with their friends they're
providing us residency um for a New
Hampshire
address representative
Hill thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my questions um if someone
applies um for Asylum and is not granted
Asylum and yet New Hampshire has issued
a driver's license are we able to get
that back so if they're issued a
driver's license it's going to be under
what their previous status was and we
only issue licenses based on the
expiration data of your credentials from
immigration so if you're issued a
one-year work employment card and that's
what you were given a license under then
your license is going to expire at the
end of that employment authorization
card term thank you
followup and if you were not granted a
uh you were not here on a work visa um
you were here because you felt you were
in danger uh in your prior
location um and you are requesting
Asylum and it is not granted what
happens to that license if you are only
here as a pending Asylum status you had
no legal status prior you're not getting
a New Hampshire license at all so we're
not renewing there's nothing to renew
you're not issued
anything thank
you representative
Gorski thank you Mr chair chairman and
thank you for taking my question um on
page two uh one of sentences that got my
attention it says once licensed the
individual shall be subject to the same
provisions of the law as all other
licenses can you explain to us what same
provisions of the law
means I don't know honestly I don't know
what the intent of this is I my
assumption of it was meaning following
the law laws of the road that you're
eligible to have your license suspended
were can you see how there could be some
concerns there because if I have a
license same provisions of the law could
mean that that allows you to do certain
things with a license that you can do
AKA vote so that that right there that
particular phrase can be quite concerned
can you see how that might be I can't
see that now that you're saying that way
I wasn't thinking that
way
much next up chair recognizes uh
representative
Perez thank you Mr chairman and thank
you members of the committee my name is
the St represent Senator Perez I
represent District 43 in Milford and I'm
here to speak in support of um Senate
bill at
501 I was one a TPS holder I was one
headed working permit and let me tell
you the way it works it wasn't easy for
me to get a driver's
license I live at Milford but I I was
told to come all the way to conquer to
get a driver's license and the driver's
license specifically had the day from my
working permit until the day that my my
working permit was expire and that was
it if I if I didn't have a new one
working permit or I didn't have a uh
like um when I got my green car and I
had a green car my driver license wasn't
Renew at all and the other thing that
I'm hearing here is like these type of
uh driver's license is going to make it
easy for people to vote let me tell you
something it took me three times to go
back to my house when I got my
citizenship to be able to register to
vote I was told that the driver's
license was not good enough because I
wasn't boarding
here I was told to go back and get my
citizenship I went back and got my
citizenship and that was not good enough
either I went back and got my us passort
it's not as easy if you guys putting in
here like people indument people or
people with temporary status uh they
they're going to have the right to vote
or illegally going to try to register to
vote or are we just hear the Polie and
document the people that give a driver's
license no it's not as easy that you
guys is
putting this is people who already have
working permit and they have the right
to be
here and then the way it works when The
aalum Seekers theal on Seekers don't get
a free open door and then they say oh
yeah you you welcome and then you can go
and get dver license no that's not the
way it works people has to go through
the system they have to apply for the
for the
asilum and then they they can get a
working permit and when they they get a
working permit they can go and apply for
the driver license it's not just like uh
free for all oh masking here to just
open the door wide open for anyone to
get a driver's license no that's not the
way it
works but what I'm hearing here for over
and over and over for many years that we
heared asking to give indument the
people the right to vote or we asking
here to uh something doing illegally I'm
tired of
that as someone who has been here for 34
plus year I went through the whole
and I'm here to represent the people
because I feel I'm giving back to the
community they open the doors for me and
make me feel
welcome I'm making sacrifices to show
you that I'm not here to take advantage
of the country I'm here to give it back
to the country as like many other
immigrants
here thank you so
much thank you any questions from the
committee see none thank you again
uh next up J recognize Henry I have no
idea what that says from the American
civil liberties Union I can read that
part of it uh not taking a position on
the bill according to this card welcome
what is your last name by my last name
thank you very much my name is Henry
clemento you are seeing the combination
of a long and unpronounced last name and
terrible pentant ship so I apologize for
that at least my name is Henry clemento
I'm a senior sta me at the ACLU of New
Hampshire um I wasn't planning on
speaking on this bill today because I'm
not involved in our immigration work uh
that's a another very capable lawyer in
my office but I do handle um all of our
elections and voting rights related work
and I just happened to be here so I
thought I might be able to elay perhaps
some of Representative C's concerns
about the registration process a person
registering to vote in New Hampshire has
to prove four qualifications their
identity their age their domicile and
their citizens
ship the the New Hampshire driver's
license can be proof of identity age and
domicile but it's never proof of
citizenship so when a non-citizen or
anybody presents to register to vote
with a New Hampshire driver's license
they're going to be able to meet three
of the four qualifications but not
necessarily the fourth to prove
citizenship you need a passport American
birth certificate um uh naturalization
papers or any other document deemed by
the supervisors of the checklist to be
reasonable proof of citizenship if you
don't have those you can sign What's
called the qualified voter affidavit
where you attest penalties of voter
fraud that you are a United States
citizen typically we see that there's
about six or 700 of those qualified
voters application affidavits attested
to every state general election for the
purpose of proving
citizenship um as far as I'm aware and I
was looking into this for another bill
that was being heard today but there are
no states in the country that currently
require documentary proof of
citizenship there was one in Kansas but
that law was struck down by the 10th
circuit so a person who's presenting
with the New Hampshire driver's license
citizen or non this this has nothing to
do with proving their citizenship their
address will be used to prove the
domicile which is a different
qualification but not citizenship and
the election officials are very well
trained on that and it's pretty clear in
the Secretary of State's election
procedure manual that that then you have
driver's license is not qualified to
approve citizenship and then in addition
that uh to what my colleague said about
falsely claiming citizenship being a
permanent bar on naturalization it's
also under the New Hampshire
Constitution a lifetime ban on voting in
the state so if that person who falsely
held themselves out to be a citizen some
however did naturalize which it sounds
like they never would they still would
have their right uh to vote permanently
removed and less restored by the
attorney general and governor and
counsel so I'm happy to take any
questions on on the voting aspect which
is really the only thing I know anything
about thanks very much any questions
from the committee representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question does that apply also
um to the ID as opposed to just the
driver's license do that does that
provide three of the four requirements
as well so you're talking about the
state issued non voter ID yes if it has
a New Hampshire address which is your
current address so I think probably
people in this committee know better
than I do that when you move you have to
update your address with TMV but you do
not have to get a new license with your
updated address so if you move and you
don't get a new updated address you're
supposed to tell the people that when
you register because it's going to have
the wrong address and now you're going
to have to prove your correct address
like when I moved to Portsmith when I
was younger my license still said Nasha
would not allow me to register to vote
in Portsmith with the NASA address but
other than that yes the non-voter the
driver's licenses and non-d Driver IDs
are operate identically to prove those
same three
qualifications okay represent s thank
you Mr chairman thank you sir for taking
my
question am I correct in understanding
that many towns now have gone to a
system where on the back of the driver's
license there's a barcode that they can
scan and it tells it only tells them the
three criteria that the license is
attend ended to approve which was that
their name where they live and their
age that's right you're talking about
the pull pads process yes that's right
and I think it's because the DMV person
would probably tell you that our DMV
database doesn't keep track of
citizenship correct so I I just want to
reaffirm that there are there's new
technology it's my understanding and I'm
looking for you to uh validate this if
possible that the new technology allows
an even more efficient use of trying to
determine the thing the things that a
driver's license should be used for and
only those things that a driver's
right it was in use in ports withth and
Manchester and maybe a few other towns
last election and it's wonderful if you
ever get a chance to vote there any
other questions seeing none thank you
very much uh I just got a late card is
this the same Eva Castillo that
one okay I thought I already got
one I think somebody may have done it
for
you yeah somebody did I thought you
might have been looking to speak again
which I can't I can't let you do so so
with that being said I have nobody else
signed up to speak I'm going to close
the public hearing on Senate Bill
501 uh just a minute to reset we'll go
on the Senate Bill 358 which is our last
I want to rec recuit why can't I say the
word recruit all your guys for uh my
committee's next door we have over a
hundred between Judiciary and commerce
so seeing that you're all done you can
help I'll deputize you partial Senators
we pay the same wages yes yes oh yes
Senate P you you can share my office
okay I'm going to open up the public
hearing on Senate Bill 358 FN relative
to invalidating out ofst state driver's
licenses issued to undocumented
immigrants uh chair recognizes Senator
Gan and Prime sponsor welcome sir thank
you Mr chair how you doing um I hope you
did I hope you saved the best for last s
on your last bill um 358 is a bill
codifying in statute that that New
Hampshire does not validate driver's
licenses from other states given
exclusively to undocumented immigrants
so very different from the last bill um
I became a became aware of this um a
year or two ago I was in Philadelphia
I'm a proud father of a sun getting his
Masters this month and I was reading in
the Philly papers where they were
issuing um licenses to illegal aliance
in in in Pennsylvania that was also
going to you're automatically then
registered to vote so just Flags went
off in my head then I started realizing
other states were doing it Massachusetts
is now giving uh out ofate un documented
aliens licenses the problem is some
states are
putting notice on it so you can see
they'll have some wording so you'll be
aware that it's not a legal resident um
other states now have for whatever be
they good or nefarious reasons just
decided to take that
off um and so that is where we're got
more concerned with it and why the
Senate voted this bill through um
current law already prohibits issuing a
New Hampshire driver's license to an
undocumented resident this legislation
would just clarified that the same
standard applies to licenses granted
from other states validating a license
for an undocumented resident causes an
incentive for more illegal immigrations
states are being forced to deal with the
open immigration policies um and that's
partially for many reasons
um just in New Hampshire last year we
had the mass murderer from Brazil we had
um in again just last year in Manchester
we had someone transporting illegal
aliens we've had the same at the
northern border we've had cases of rape
we've have cases of assault and um as
you all watch TV you see the same thing
that I'm seeing that there are problems
with the Border um partially because
we're not betting people at the border
and that's 8 to 10 million I won argue
what the exact number is with anyone um
but it's a large number and the problem
is they're not being vetted at the
border and that does not count which um
border patrol is estimating there's
another 10 or 15% of Goda aways who
haven't even encountered anyone we have
no idea they're even here um custom and
border patrol last year had uh 169
individual terrorists that were caught
at the southern border um who are on
this watch list um we had 36,000 with
criminal convictions and again we don't
know how many people were got aways that
never were checked by anyone so it is a
consideration and we in New Hampshire
for several reasons want to we being the
Senate want to look into who's here why
they're here and if we're giving them a
driver's license um 358 is a tool you
know we're saying I come my grandparents
are legal immigrants just like many
people who went before me and we totally
appreciate
and realize the necessary presence and
they're doing good work in New Hampshire
they're good people raising families but
again we're not betting enough of the
people so when other states are giving
illegal aliens drivers licenses it's
going to present many problems um and
would rather them state if another state
wants to give a resident a driver's
license or then in like a sanctuary
State like Massachusetts we're not one
of them and we're not encouraging that
um this bill invalidates licenses where
the license is issued exclusively to
undocumented immigrants or the license
is substantially the same as licenses
issued to Citizens residents or those
lawfully present in the United States
but has markings again we have two types
some states are putting markings
establishing that they're a non-citizen
others are not and they're just giving
regular drivers licenses of this bill
does not invalidate licenses that are
exactly the same as licenses issued by
state to lawful pres citizens this bill
does not require police officers to
question anyone Whose license does not
have identifiable markings or is
indicating the person is undocumented
there'll be no profiling here the New
Hampshire DMV has said the
implementation of giving licenses to
illegal aliens would increase the
opportunity for fraudulent activities
regarding identity documentation and
documentation regarding residency
assuming an ID like this would be the
start of allowing access to Safe public
Public Services needed by Lael New
Hampshire citizens the state of
Massachusetts is paying a billion
dollars now supporting their legal
aliens we cannot follow the same we
can't afford it in summary if you're in
the United States illegally you should
not pass or possess a state issue
driver's license thank you Mr
chairman thank you any questions from
the committee represent Gorski thank you
Mr chairman and thank you senator for
taking my question uh we've been hearing
the term lawful presence and um all
pretty much today your bill says lawful
presence what does lawful presence in
your bill mean so and I was listening to
your testimony before to me lawful
presence if you have so we have groups
of people who here who haven't gone they
haven't their gotway or whatever you
want to call them and so that's a big
problem and it's of itself but if you
have gone through as I understand I am
an attorney but am not an immigration's
attorney as I understand it once you've
technically are legally here you know
you've gone through some I I I'm not
sure anyway so that would be a good
question for an immigration attorney to
answer you
specifically I'll avoid it any other
questions representative St
Clair thank you Mr
chair and I would like one followup uh
Mr chair chair in your in your speech I
guess uh you talked about terrorists you
talked about people coming I think from
the southern border of the United States
definitely from the northern border I'm
just trying to wrap my head around what
that has to do with driver's licenses
that have been issued by Massachusetts
or other states where people have
identification granted by by that state
but I I don't get what that has to do
with the issue you talked about at the
border they'll be driving in our state
so you have S you have people from other
countries who have not been vetted we do
not know if they're criminals we don't
know anything about their background and
you're going to be allowing them into
New Hampshire this bill would be saying
that if you issue another state issues
an illegal alien or undocumented citizen
whatever you want to
call we're we're saying we haven't beded
those people we don't know want them
driving on our streets they could come
to New Hampshire they couldn't get a
driver's license in New Hampshire they
don't meet the credentials that we have
set up so just because another state has
done that doesn't mean we want to accept
what they've done so as far as
reciprocity I have run this by our legal
council and the Senate and they did not
find a problem on this would follow up
please thank you and you you said that
some states have markings on the
driver's license but other states don't
yes so how do you expect law enforcement
to tell the difference between these
drivers that you want to ban from
driving in the state of New Hampshire so
just because there are enforcement
issues here so the ones that say non you
know if you I don't there's two or three
states that put a recognition that
you're not an American citizen they'll
say non-citizen whatever they say on the
license so when if someone pulls them
over they will know right away the other
ones just because there is an
enforcement problem doesn't mean the
policy is improper the policy here is we
do not want to have people who haven't
been vetted bringing be coming to New
Hampshire and there is enforcement
problems with the ones that don't say
anything but where there's technically
not going to be legal in New
Hampshire thank you any other
questions representative SES thank you
Mr chairman thank you senator for taking
my question thank you did I understand
you correctly to say
that a person who is a uh non-citizen
who achieves driving privileges in
another state coming driving in this
state would be potentially subject to
further penalties for driving under that
type of license that is
correct
so a a followup thank you Mr chairman
keep me on track here
um I guess I'm struggling with with the
we give
noncitizens drivers licenses here in New
Hampshire all the time and other states
Give noncitizens driving privileges all
the time and in fact many of those folks
may actually live in Maine or wherever
and drive over into the Hampshire to
work and you're now saying no they can't
do that no if you're here on a studio
stud visa for instance or a J1 work visa
you would certainly be able to have that
license it's when you're an
undocumented immigrant who hasn't gone
through any vetting that we would not
allow you to drive on our streets
technically I have to follow I I I'll
let me finish that part though so there
is an enforcement it's easy to have the
states that put non-citizen those ones
will be easy the others we won't know if
there's a driving an accident okay I'm
sorry I'm not answering your question
you're not that that's the problem I'm
having EXC did you one more yes I'm
sorry but I this
is this is an
important point that is trying to be uh
to so you you made the statement you
made the statement Senator that states
that put noncitizenship
status on their driver's license that
would be easy for us to follow follow
yes and do what well you would not be
legally driving on New Hampshire
roadways if in that in your scenario if
it was an undocumented immigrant driving
on our roads and it's said non US
citizen how do you how will you know
which is which well I'll know on the
ones that the ones that are stamped I
will know you are correct in saying that
they'll be in it is just because our
policy is we do not in the Senate what
we passed was we do not want people who
haven't been vetted so when it says
non-citizen you'll know right away it
just because we have enforcement
problems doesn't mean the policy is
wrong I understand your enforcement
policy in some situations with the ones
that like in Massachusetts if they you
come here tomorrow and they gave you as
an undocumented immigrant they gave you
a driver's license tomorrow after you
just got here they know nothing about
you and we think that that is going to
be a magnet for
problems you may not agree with that
representative Hill thanks Mr chairman
yes
representative thank you for coming um
I'll give this a shot and I think this
is the question several of us have sure
how would someone that received a
driver's license that is a non US
citizen but here on a green card um
green card would be fine but how would
the the but the license that that person
receives in Indiana and comes here to
drive wouldn't say here on a green card
it would just say non US citizens so if
we go to the bill itself I believe it'll
answer our question okay um if they're
unable to prove presence in the US when
the license is issued the driver's
license or permit reporting to authorize
the holder of a motor vehicle on Pro
public roadways it is valid invalid in
the state does not authorize the holder
to operate a motor vehicle in the state
so it's when they have unable to prove
lawful presence then they would not be
validly driving in New Hampshire roads
proving this will be very hard I will
grant you that but doesn't mean the
policy is bad it means falling through
in the real world part is bad in that
Val so does this then become a papers
please what a papers please law you have
to prove that you're here legally no in
order to to be here did not at all times
when the police ask you if you were so
if they pulled you over for speeding and
you had one of the licenses from a state
that tagged you noncitizen or they would
tag you then we would know that but we
would not know and we would only find
out it one thing we don't want people to
be issued out of if they come here with
an out ofate license we think it's
problematic that then they could go for
a New Hampshire state license and turn
that state license in so we think that's
a potential problem we think it's a
potential problem for you know Aid which
um if you have people here you're going
to have to support and pay for some of
these people who have no assets of their
own so we think it it can lead to other
problems besides the driving problems so
there is Enforcement issue problems when
people have a license that looks exactly
the same as US citizens from
Massachusetts coming here from other
countries with that same license it will
be problematic to enforce it and we will
not profile they will not ask
anyway you follow so in order to travel
to New Hampshire I would have to carry
my passport if I'm not a US citizen so I
have to IM immigrate into New Hampshire
every time I come across the if you come
if you're an undocumented immigrant with
a Massachusetts license they pull you
over for a traffic violation they're not
going to ask you it's they're not
allowed to profile you if there was a
car accident you might have problems is
an insurance company going to cover you
have you do have insurance um so there
are other potential problems
but we couldn't prove it in that
instance we can only prove it when it
non-citizen
anybody
new other questions seeing n thank you
representative okay the the pile
continues to grow here with every
minute so let's do
this we are going to see most people are
requesting three minutes so three
minutes it will be and we will we will
be
timing so we'll start with uh chair
recognizing Christine Wellington in
support no opposition to the bill sorry
minutes thank you chairman Walsh and
members of the committee um just want to
as briefly as possible just say that
this um bill will cause more harm than
it will do good um there's currently 21
jurisdictions 19 States and two
territories Puerto Rico and uh District
District of col Columbia that allow
driver licenses just to undocumented
folks living within their
jurisdictions um this bill is appears to
be modeled after a Florida bill that was
enacted and went into effect in July
Florida um initially had five states
five states only that they said they
were not going to um honor uh those
licenses and they had to um scale it
back down to too so for all of this
helloo there's two states that they're
going to focus in on um these things are
going to whether intended to do so or
not um because of the fear-mongering
that accompanies this kind of
legislation is very much going to raise
the risk of profiling and holding
somebody on the side of the road for too
long trying to figure out what the heck
is lawful presence it's too confusing
and it does not reflect I believe and
many of us believe New Hampshire values
um so I we it it and it's also if if we
really did have a value that we want to
stop everybody that's undocumented from
coming into the state um then we are
letting a whole bunch of folks um able
to drive here with Massachusetts
licenses and other licenses New
Hampshire and Maine I believe are the
only two states right now that don't
allow um undocumented people that meet
certain benchmarks from being able to
obtain a driver's license um there it's
fundamentally unfair for somebody who
has gone to their own State DMV and
jumped through all the Hoops they have
and yes if you're a Massachusetts
resident You by law must have insurance
to to unbeknown to them um be able to um
be um penalized and um cited for driving
without a license after you've done
everything you could because the state
you live in allows you to do that um it
doesn't promote highway safety because
people who have driver's licenses
presumably are um trained and have to
pass certain Benchmark tests it will
also be a bureaucratic nightmare for the
DMV to try to figure out as the laws EV
flow throughout the United States who
they're supposed to um declare our um
holders of licenses that might be
suspect I think that's all I have to say
at this point in time thank you very
much thank you any questions from the
committee represent Gorski thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question you mentioned there was 19
states that give licenses to one
documented immigrants from your
knowledge do all 19 States use the same
vetting
process they each state has their own as
we do regulations Etc and I I I have not
researched the vetting process for any
of the states I would be happy and I can
follow up with um if if members are
interested with a a handout of the list
of states that do allow um licenses to
un documented people I can't
specifically recall if there's
you why am
I representative Lyn I apologize but yes
if you want to take representative
seller's seat that' be great
recognizes representative Perez and
opposition to the bill looking for three
back thank you again for um allowing me
to speak again my name is representative
Perez um I represent District 43 in
Milford
let me take it moment to get myself
together these Bill makes me angry first
of all we're not talking about
animals we're not talking about people
or things with two heads and two bodies
we talking about
humans their term illegal aliens is used
over and over and over and
over and the way people speaking about
people who look like me and people who
look like many of you and your community
is
shameful shame on all the ones that they
aliens many of you probably coming from
indument the families that you don't
is I'm here
and speaking in opposition in this bill
why if the other stays given driver
license why are we going take advantage
and then allow them not taking away the
driver's license we want to keep in
track of these people when they come
into the
state taking away the driver's license
is taking away the way for you to know
it's a stupidity to think that by taking
away the right for people to drive in
New Hampshire is going to help you to
chase them away from the state
no think P before you pass or like try
to introduce this stupid stuff like this
you're pushing me sorry would you like
to speak yes about the Bill yes and I'm
speaking about the bill one more insult
about stupid
or anything of the sort and you're
done thank you thank you for remind me
that others use the language and they
don't
get
punished but I'm here to speak in
because again my husband is a d as he's
he's a license nutrician he looks like
me he has a electrical license in
massachusett
Vermont New Hampshire so imagine my
husband live in another state and have a
driver license from another state and
come in here to be an electrician that
we we need the workers here and you talk
you're going to tell an electrician for
another state because they look like
certain way that they has to prove that
US citizen that has to carry the US
passport in order to come in and work in
New Hampshire because otherwise you're
going to be profiled this is what the
bill is going to do that's why I'm not
supporting this bill and I'm asking you
not to support this bill thank
you thank you representative any
much uh next up chff recognizes Eva
Castillo Jon representing a opposition
hatred does not grow in Granite it
really is offensive diminishing to hear
the war alien here alien there and to
have somebody that to introduce a bill
and just refer about criminals here
criminal I counted seven aliens times
illegals that's pretty sad this bill
doesn't make any
sense the only way to enforce this bill
would be to establish profiling because
you know what are we what message are we
sending if you come from Massachusetts
stay away because you know if if there's
any issues there we do not we do not
accept this is going to leave New
Hampshire isolated from the rest of the
nation so many people come to New
Hampshire for the New Hampshire
advantage to come shopping to our
beautiful mountains and tourists you
think they're going to want to be coming
here if they have if they have bills
like this that don't even recognize what
other states have in their laws it's bad
enough that we do not license on
documented people here and by the way no
human being is
illegal uh but
why why who who are we to tell all the
states what to do are we going to start
just pulling out Massachusetts cars to
see if they there's no way to enforce
this this build makes no logic no sense
whatsoever other than hatred and and
misunderstandings and and you can tell
that people don't quite understand the
immigration system in this country it's
so complicated so complex there's so
many different ways to be here you know
legally our our our DMV already does a
wonderful job enforcing and making sure
that whoever is here legally can get a
driver's license let's not just you know
start legislating all the
other states this bill is does nothing
for New Hampshire other than send a bad
message that we do not want you here if
you're from another state and that are
laws your laws don't apply here and we
don't want you
here you know New Hampshire this is not
the New Hampshire way this is not the
New Hampshire that we all live and
love and please put a human face that
thank you and God bless you and I keep
my passport with me at all times thank
you for your testimony and for the
record until the legal definition
changes it is appropriate to use the
words illegal alien that is a legal
definition until that changes it is not
an the president instructed USCIS to do
not refer to people as aliens I do I
respect your request but again it is a
legal
uh next up CH will recognize and I truly
apologize I
cannot recognize this Leo vas possibly
how' I do all right thank you uh in
opposition to the bill welcome to
transportation
thank you sir um my name is Leo Vos I am
a president of the New Hampshire
resident
Council uh down in nashille New
Hampshire and I'm opposing this bill uh
because of some problems I see regarding
the how would would be able uh to Ved
the people who's driving with license
from another state
uh as the other person talked here all
around us we already they other states
already let immigrants without documents
to have driver's license uh she said
that Maine doesn't but Maine does too so
Maine Vermont and Massachusetts so the
only state up here that doesn't is New
Hampshire and I'm opposing this bill not
because of other states are doing
something else it it is because an
immigrant I know a lot of immigrants
that lives outside of New Hampshire
including my mother in-law and a couple
friends of mine that always come into my
house they are some of them uh are
citizens some of them they are in work
visas some of them are with green
cards and I don't want
to be chaotic but let's put it this way
if they been
stopped they'll be the cops will be
asking them if
they they have status or not if that
would be the case would be something but
by this bill it says that the the
policemen won't be able to do that
because if there is no uh signs if there
is nothing different on the license they
won't be able to ask therefore none of
the states that I just mentioned has any
markings saying that the person does not
have status here
so my my problem with this bill is what
is this bill doing other than just uh
making people afraid of coming here even
though they have license from other
state so uh I always like to say that we
always react um for the stuff that we
don't know
and that and this is one thing that we
don't know the immigrants when I say
that of we are just afraid to to come
here and be pulled over or not not get
deported because the people already has
uh status but to have persecution
or stuff like that so uh that's why I
came here today to out of my time to
please see if we can uh take a look at
the legal part of this because the way
it it is it has a lot of holes for us to
to put it as a Bill thank you thank you
very much questions from the
you chair recognizes and you're you're
going to be upset with me I forgot your
last name pronunciation Henry from the
ACLU New
Hampshire please state your name when
here hi thank you again my name is Henry
Clement toich I'm a senior staff
attorney at the ACLU of New Hampshire I
think others have spoken compellingly
about how this bill is an invitation to
racial profiling and probably impossible
to enforce
um but there's one other thing that I
haven't yet heard that I just wanted to
mention which is about the breakdown of
the interstate compact so Driver's
Licensing in New Hampshire is based on
the idea that a driver's license issued
in one state is going to be valid in the
other 49 states because as soon as you
start shipping away at that the whole
system of interstate commerce can like
pretty quickly come crumbling down so
what do I mean by that well imagine if
uh in response to this another state
said yeah well you don't like our policy
of giving driver's licenses to
undocumented folks and we don't like
your policy of giving driver licenses to
16-year-old so we're not going to allow
any New Hampshire driver under the age
of 18 to drive on the roadways in our
state or another state that says you
don't like our policy about giving
driver licenses to undocumented folks we
don't like your policy about uh not
using real ID so any New Hampshire
driver's license that's not real ID
doesn't count in our state as soon as we
start pulling out the threads of the
interstate driving compact it becomes a
nightmare for New Hampshire operators
because now everyone's got to keep a
list in their head of I know I have a
driver's license but what states am I
actually allowed to drive in again and
that can change there's no Central list
anywhere I just think it would be
um chaotic to say the least if people
had to start worrying about you know if
States had to worry that other states
were targeting their licenses so um
I think we can all agree that the
roadways are safer when more people who
are driving have licenses they're more
likely to have insurance they're more
likely to have gone through driver head
they're more likely to stop and wait for
the police if there's a fender bender
and just as a blanket reason pulling
away people's driver's licenses that
have nothing really to do with roadway
safety is only going to lead to bigger
issues on the roadway so for those
reasons uh ACU of New Hampshire opposes
this bill and hopes that you'll itl it
and I'm happy to take any questions
thank you any questionss from the
committee representative
SE thank you Mr chairman thank you sir
um is there any aspect to this that
would fall under the concern that it is
an undo undue process or um that would
violate rights otherwise
um I'm I'm concerned about that and I'm
not loyal so I don't know the answer so
yeah yeah it's a great question and um I
have to apologize to the committee in
that my boss was supposed to be
testifying on this bill but he ended up
in Portugal and I ended up with you all
so is he is he surfing yeah so everyone
should feel really bad for me and really
good for him um so I only got a chance
to sort of think about this starting
yesterday but there's a provision of the
Constitution that says that states are
to give the full faith and credit to
documents of other states you know we've
seen that in the context um of marriage
equality where some states were you know
issuing marriage licenses to other
states or to same-sex couples and other
states were not accepting that and it
became like this total hodg podge and a
real mess and um I think there there is
a Doctrine and I'm I'm not an expert on
it so I don't know exactly how it would
shake out here but the words that come
to mind more than due process are full
faith and credit maybe that's the answer
I wish I had I wish I had a better
answer for you but I I am concerned that
there's a constitutional problem yep
well
okay yeah so I want to try and summarize
that
so um you
there there may in fact be a problem
with due process but it would take
further investigation to know
that yeah I I'm not aware so this is a
new this has happened in one other state
I don't think that there's been any um
Court decisions yet involving this
whether this is constitutional or not
but anytime you do some sort of Cutting
Edge thing like this where you start
taking away people's rights you know
following a path that hasn't been
explicitly blessed by the courts you do
run that risk and so I think the answer
is we don't yet
know whether you know what the courts
would do something with something like
this I don't know if we were talking
about rights or are we talking about the
privilege of driving but representative
Hill thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um wouldn't it be
somewhat analogous to uh a a a gun owner
from New Hampshire trying to drive to
Florida and having difficulty navigating
um I think as far as I know New
Hampshire is isolated as well um and
having a difficult time driving through
massachusett to Vermont and New York um
so would would that not be somewhat
similar to the current situation that
this bill would
Envision it's a great question and this
hearing I'm I'm afraid is rapidly
becoming just a list of things that I'm
not an expert in and and gun law is one
of them but it's a little bit different
we make our living on talking about
things that we don't know much about I
um um I guess what I'll say is U and you
may you're probably right that there's
an issue with States not recognizing
other States Concealed Carry Permits or
whatever they are but it is a little bit
different I think in that driving on the
roadways is sort of like the backbone of
Interstate Commerce in the way that like
traveling with a gun and using a gun you
know is is not and I'm not really a gun
person so maybe people will disagree
with me on that and maybe I'm totally
wrong but I do think that there's a
distinction in that like when we drive
from one state to another you know we we
expect all the signs to be the same
color we expect the speed limits to be
on the right side of the road no states
are like switching from the right side
of the road to the left side of the road
we're sort of expecting that everything
that works in one state is more or less
going to work in the other state and
that's like why the interstate system
works so well and as soon as we start
monking with that I think that's when
you're going to end up with
problems and I think your right and
privileges question was rhetorical but
but from a legal perspective when well
it is a privilege to drive it becomes a
vested interest once you get a driver's
license and you do end up actually
having some due process rights before
that can be taken away because
just because something is a privilege
doesn't mean the government can
arbitrarily take it away so but I
understand you two have been making your
point thanks for getting I know you had
to get the last word in but just lawyer
just as a reminder and as a reminder to
the committee too the prime sponsor did
testify that he ran this through the
Senate legal and they had no issues with
it constitutionally so thank you very
much thank
you our next step chair recognizes it's
been a long time Bruno de
how are you sir I'm doing well how are
you doing I'm doing well and I have to
remind you I've been timing everybody
out three minutes all right no sound I'm
going to to be brief uh good afternoon
uh Mr chair and members of the committee
uh my name is Vern de Brito I'm
executive director of the New Hampshire
Brazilian Council and an immigration
lawyer and I'm here today in speaking
opposition of this bill um it is my my
opinion though that
this bill will be a kind of warms of
lawsuits potential lawsuits and the
reason being is under the 10th Amendment
the states do have the power to pass
laws pertaining to the police power and
licenses uh is part of the the policing
power that are reserved to to the
states however uh some of the the
provisions of um this bill um it is my
opinion that it may be some violation of
a due process because in order to to
determine that someone is here
undocumented you will have to ask
additional documentations besides the
driver's license and at the moment that
you ask someone to issue to present
their Visa or passport or a state in the
United States then you are stepping on
to the federal government uh Power which
is immigration enforcing immigration
laws uh we have had uh this issue
already ruled by the Supreme Court in
2012 us V Arizona and recently most
recently I'm sure uh most if not all of
you have followed uh USV Taxas and it's
a very uh difficult
situation um as my colleague mentioned
the the Full Faith and Credit Clause
must be abided by uh the Constitution
it's under article 4 section 1 and the
states must respect the court orders and
laws from other states if other states
decide that uh same-sex marriage is um
is valid New Hampshire cannot come in
and say we're not going to accept it it
just doesn't fly and because of those
reasons it is my opinion that New
Hampshire is going to be sued if this
law comes into effect thank you so much
and I wish you guys have a great
afternoon thank you sir any questions
from the committee CNN you have a great
recognizes alio
Costa and I forget the I can't read the
prefects P pastor sir thank you sir
welcome good afternoon my name is uh
aloise yosta I'm a pastor of the
Assembly of God bth in Nashua so I'm
here to oppose this bill and I will try
to explain my reasons I'm also
representing the churches around uh
Nashua
Manchester um in the
areas uh I'm very concerned about this
bill because because I have kids behind
me they're all from my church and they
are they all born here but if you look
at their faces they don't look
Americans but they are
Americans how my three kids are born
here and they have my
face so how how we going to identify
this people how we going to find out the
American and the one that we think there
have no right to be
here uh also I think this bill is going
to work against the state of New
Hampshire
because everywhere I go I try to
advocate for the New Hampshire State
because people say that New Hampshire is
a discrimin
discriminatory State and I always say no
this is all a met it's not true
I live there and I know the
people I'm always involved with the
meetings and stuff and I don't see
difference between New Hampshire and
Massachusetts or other states but with
this it's going to be impossible for me
to defend the the state of New Hampshire
in that
aspect and and I think the reason why I
think it's going to work against the
state of New Hampshire I mean the uh
Bruno was saying about the lawsuits but
also uh for the
businesses uh for example my church we
rent the space for 16 years already we
about to buy a piece of land and build a
church guess what I'm not going to look
up piece of land in New Hampshire you
might not care about it but I'm not here
by myself I represent many
people uh my in my inclination is going
to
be look somewhere
else and not not only a church but
businesses Leo is a
businessman he deals with New Hampshire
Massachusetts Maine he's got work in
Maine work in
Massachusetts he's got people that come
from Massachusetts to work for him or
vice and verse
what's going to be we're going to have
to go somewhere else we're going to
survive we're going to find a way
out for example
Julie Juliana she's here she's the
youngest one here both of her
grandparents live in
Massachusetts how they how they going to
come visit her even though they're
legal but it's going to be hard I I
serve a lot of people people in
Massachusetts people with depression
anxiety they come to my office they're
afraid can I get you to close it up Sir
oh okay I gave everybody three I got all
right I'm sorry I'm sorry I wasn't
paying attention to the time but uh that
that's what I that's what I just want to
live with you guys uh to think about the
human part of this and think about New
Hampshire thank you very much
thank you sir any questions from the
again okay I have nobody else signed up
to speak on Senate Bill 358 so I'm going
to close the public
hearing uh give you a quick rundown of
what's going on next I've got some good
news some not so good news the good news
is after speaking with the clerk I
cannot EXA any bills other than the one
that we have on the schedule today
because they were heard a couple of
weeks ago not today uh bad news is I
need everybody to leave the room except
the Republicans because we're going to
decide what to do with Senate Bill 471
for a few
minutes um so to to make it official
that's fine to make it official only
because of the time I'm going to open up
the executive session on Senate Bill
471 and I'm going to recess the
o'
e
folks it's beautiful
afternoon I will open up the I reopen
the executive session on Senate Bill 471
FN relative to adding a speed limit of
45 miles hour on Rural highways chair
recognizes representative Gorski for a
motion thank you Mr chair I make a
motion for itl on
s471 motion is inexpedient to legislate
is there a second seconded by
representative foot you to speak to your
motion sir I do thank you um you know
although there was some uh testimony
about some of the uh troubled rows that
they mentioned one of the things that
just kind of came glaring out to me is
that the dot has the ability to do what
this bill attends to do and um I think
what they're just looking for is
something in statute and to me I think
since they already have the ability to
do this there's no need for this bill
and that's why I I'm voting for
itl anybody else from the committee
representative St
Clair yes thank you I have a question
that representative you can help me with
you said that um they already have the
statute to do this this is just
them what I said is they had the ability
to do what this bill intended to do and
all they wanted to do was put something
in statute so my question to you is what
is the harm then of the bill there's no
right representes
thank so um
one piece of data that I that is missing
but I think is was in this case we'll
um notes from people who live in the
near these roads is that what are the
numbers of fatalities that are occurring
in these these gra these types of roads
and because we don't have that data it's
an unfortunate aspect of it but I I do
believe that the anecdotal evidence that
was given to us that lots of fatalities
are occurring on these roads is a huge
cause of concern for me in addition to
that I don't believe that the the
Hampshire do is going around trying to
introduce bills and opening up those
kinds of questions for things that they
don't feel that they need they obviously
did this because they felt there was a
need
um Mr Lambert from the New Hampshire do
spoke in favor of the bill and he did so
because he wanted to remind us
that many of the states roads and that's
what we're talking about fall between
the 35 and the 55 mile per hour and
sometimes it's inappropriate to be 35
and sometimes it's inappropriate to be
55 and they were looking for another
tool in their tool box and I can't think
of any good reason why we wouldn't
provide the tools necessary for them to
do their jobs and to keep the motoring
public
safer we all know
that many many roads in New Hampshire
have gone from a nice quiet byway that
you drove down and you looked at the
scenery and you enjoyed yourself and you
had fun maybe took the family to a
destination where you'd have a picnic or
whatever
to curb Cuts everywhere cars come coming
out everywhere very few
uh mechan um uh intersections that had
uh light
control um and it's always
better quite frankly when this
legislature takes up and takes action on
things that are within its
purview state speed limits are within
our purview we are the ones who can
choose to make those changes I believe
that we should make those changes in
this instance thank
you anybody else from the
committee representative
Smith thank you Mr chair um kind of to
bolster up what representative Gorski
said this is a blanket solution how many
roads will be affected by this I don't
know I reviewed the testimony and I
didn't see that data are we going to
have a bunch of bunch of roads that need
to immediately go from 55 to 45 because
we change the standard is that going to
affect in that case the tickets that are
written because the posted speed limit
we know the signs are to let the public
know about the statute but the statute
much like much like a stop sign or a
missing one is the guiding rule of law
what happens then that seems like it's a
mess signs are expensive there's no cost
on this bill for that reason alone I
can't report it obviously if the Bill's
effective and it's going to go out and
change a bunch of speed limits then
there's going to be a cost and I'm
pretty sure it's going to be more than
the 10 grand we let go so without
knowing the cost and it being a blanket
solution where maybe some of these roads
are no problem I can't support
it anybody else from the
committee represent foot thank you Mr
chair uh I could be mistaken I didn't
get a chance to look at it in detail
with that study that was passed around
previously when the presentation was
given I believe that um speed was not a
a contributing factor to a lot of those
accidents so I just for the record
that's that's not the only Factor
involving many of these fatalities so
that would have no effect on
this or minimal like
that representative St Clair thank you
Mr chair you're right because I pointed
it out to you yeah as I as I pointed out
to a lot of people and and I
um I would probably disagree with what
uh representative Sykes brought up about
the fatalities and all that stuff
because I don't I don't necessarily
think that that's really what we should
be talking about here what we're talking
about is the
dot and maybe it isn't they can do it
now they want to be able to make this
easier form but they can lower the speed
limit not to 35 but to 40
which we I guess would be more
reasonable for them or they can raise it
from
35 to 40 versus to 55 and I can speak
experience uh at least with Mr Lambert
how we got something fixed in my well
right outside of my district in the town
of Guilford where we had a literally a
speed trap which I've spoken to some of
you about where I got them to move the
35 M hour sign
down the road a bit because it wasn't
logical where it was it had been for
years stupid so
um I just tend to think that if this is
going to if they're asking us to do this
it's logical that because there's no
reason not to and I understand about the
cost of signs but I've never thought
that that hell I can give him some signs
it's not a big deal thank you you
apparently haven't seen the price of
them but anybody else from the committee
represent
Jones Thank you Mr chair um yeah I will
be opposing the itl um simply because
this came from the dot they asked for
this it's another tool they can use it
doesn't mean we're going to go around
changing the speed limits all over and
there is protections it has to be
approved by the municipality before it
can happen so uh I think there is enough
protections that we're not going to go
changing everything uh willy-nilly so uh
I'll be opposing the IDE thank you
anybody else I'm going to give you one
more rep St Clair and a good you know
and I appreciate that um I believe that
the municipalities or the locals would
be the ones that would go to Dot and ask
for this change wasn't that the
testimony we
had some of the testimony we heard today
was from town from people in towns that
had requested the change had not gotten
it okay because the traffic study did
not support it they didn't support what
they
wanted right but somebody said that they
would have be happy with this bill they
requested 40 wasn't it and this would be
45 and they and they requested they said
that would be a good compromise
something along no they they asked 35 I
think they wanted 35 no they wanted 40
the traffic survey said 50 was what the
what the road could support um that's
why the deal didn't recommend the change
or make the change and and that's part
of my issue when you're done with with
what this bill does so okay thank
you anybody else from the
committee seeing none I'll be opposing
it also uh for a couple of reasons a I
agree with representative Sykes i' like
to see a little B more data when we make
changes like this uh we don't have any
data on the on the crashes the reasons
for the crashes and and their frequency
uh actually to the contrary about data I
saw more politics in our hearing today
uh doing exactly what it was just
mentioned towns that were unsuccessful
getting a lowering of the speed limit
that they want without having any
factual reasoning and science from the
Department to to justify it and that's
what scares me because as soon as you
introduce a blanket definition of an
unimproved rural Highway technically
these roads are going to have to be
reduced to 45 miles an hour in a lot of
cases you're not going to want to see 45
milph there you're going to prefer the
55 that used to be there once again
you've heard me say it sometimes one
size fits all does not work and that's
what I don't like about this um I could
continue but I think the point's been
made uh if nobody else has anything to
speak I will ask the clerk to call the
rule when she is
ready and you are okay so the motion on
the floor is in expedient to legislate
471 Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
de yes representative foot yes
representative C yes representative Lynn
yes representative Coker yes
representative Sykes no representative
Rich no representative Sinclair no
representative Fox no representative uh
Roda no representative Veo no
representative Jones no Representative
kundan no representative Calabro no
yes 10 to 10 the motion of inexpedient
to legislate fails is there another
motion represent pondon thank you Mr
chair I move uh for an not to pass okay
moot motion is not to pass is there a
second seconded by
representative colro I will get it soon
it's only been day
okay uh the cler will'll call the rule
the motion
is to pass on Senate Bill 471 speak
Representative corsky
no oh I'm sorry I apologize I I get out
a sequence to you care to speak to your
motion sir I I would Mr chair thank you
um as to rehash some of the comments
were already made but I want to just
make
emphasis this is requested we had a lot
of testimony in favor it was requested
by the do primarily as an additional
tool in their toolbox for our
roads it isn't strictly just a do the
municipalities are an initial key player
in this legislation as well in many
communities the regional Planning
Commission
so this isn't done Podge Podge
willy-nilly throughout the state there
is a lot of oversight that will allow
this additional tool in the areas where
it's
appropriate um as testified I would make
our roads safer uh by either reducing
the speed to 45 where it's currently 55
because they don't have any other
leverage unless they go to 35 or in some
cases increasing the speed uh to 45 in
un making the roads uniform I believe uh
like Route 112 was one of the examples
where the speed constantly goes up and
down up and down up and down where all
we really need is Unified speed and in
areas where there's shot curves we post
this the warning signs of curve ahead
and to reduce speed we do it now
throughout the states those signs are
readily available uh regarding cost we
manufacture our signs now whether it's
20 M an hour 25 30 35 55 65 70 miles an
hour it's NE it's it's negligible we
make these signs
anyways we still make them it's just you
know these are additional signs for an
additional
tool
um I did not write down all the roots
but I know rout 112 the can and 102 with
two key roots that were mentioned and
and I know for one that route 102
through Hudson uh London Dairy and dairy
are extremely high accident counts um
and that's a road that really needs to
be looked at and I would concur with the
other roads that were mentioned I think
there were probably seven or eight that
were that were pointed to but on those
points but especially giving our
doot a tool to work with to make our
roads safer I think it's uh uh this has
should have an OP to pass and give do
the uh freedom to use the tool at their
disposal thank you Mr
chair represent Smith thank you as to
the cost they're not free if you recall
well you might not but when we had the
bill to add the move over signs to the
highways we were shocked to find out
that they were
$16,000 each the cost includes not only
the posts and materials we don't make
the posts we do buy the posts but then
also the crew to put it in any site work
that needs to be done is not free
there's a lot involved how much is it my
point is I don't know and you don't
either and that's why you should not
vote for this bill you should never vote
for something that has a wide open price
tag another tragic flaw in the bill is
who they ask about the cost the judicial
branch the judicial counsel the
Department of Justice the Department of
Corrections whatever the association of
counties and the New Hampshire Municipal
Association I'm not really sure what
help those two groups could possibly
have been but they did not bother to ask
a do to pull a simple query from their
database how many miles a road are
affected how many signs are on those
roads what's the price tag it isn't
indeterminable it's that nobody bothered
to determine it for that reason alone if
this thing was going to bring sunshine
and butterflies to every little child in
the state I would still vote against it
without knowing the price tag thank you
Mr
chair anybody else from the
committee I'll finish up with this to
respond to representative pondon I agree
the Department of Transportation does
have the authority to customize the
speed limits when we have hazardous
situations curves windy roads big big
humps that aren't as common as they used
to be they used to be a lot of fun but
the problem with this bill is it sets
the bar at a different place so right
now the bar for Rural highways is $55
miles an hour they can make the
exceptions for safety and for the road
conditions at a lower speed they can do
that now currently my problem is on
those roads that they now with statute
and a definition of what a rural
unapproved interstate I mean a state
road is technically the way this is
written they all have to go to 45 is The
Benchmark there's no going back up to 55
and as you heard from Mr Lambert that
most of the roads that we have well I
won't say most many uh still using the
85 percentile and doing a traffic survey
or study still puts those roads at above
50 to 55 miles an hour and I'm sorry I
our state law still says that you're
responsible basically for what's in
front of you and you're you're
responsible to lower your speed limits
based on the conditions and the hazards
in front of you to just blanketly lower
speed limits uh that you're going to
have to stick with 24/7 whether they're
it's sunny and dry and no humans in
front of you or not I think it's the
wrong direction so for that I will be
voting against the opop
pass seeing nobody else I will ask the
clerk to call the RO on the motion of a
to
pass Vice chairman Gorski no
representative Smith no clerk votes no
representative Hill no representative de
no representative foot no representative
C no representative Lynn no
representative Coker no representative
Sykes yes representative Rich yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Gera yes representative AO yes
representative Jones yes representative
pondan yes representative Calabro yes
represent Johnson yes and chairman wall
no 10 to 10
okay so the motion about the pass fails
as well so here we are I just spoke with
the ranking member offering an interim
study I guess we're not going anywhere
with
that um with are there any other motions
I'll put it to the floor I don't have
complete control of this
place seeing no other motions I guess
we're going to move this to the calendar
is no recommendation when it gets as you
know uh to the floor the uh the
recommendation will be out the pass and
will take it from there in the full
house uh so that being said I will close
the executive session on Senate Bill
471 in terms of reports what's that are
we doing any reports um The Minority
Report anybody do well actually you're
going to be doing the the pass motion
somebody somebody over here will do a
okay thank you so do that is that the
majority report no no just with the way
this works we're going to
have a motion I mean a report in favor
about the pass and a report supporting
okay so I don't
need got
it
home I wanted to do that I don't know if
I
will no
calendar what sorry I'm looking to see
the
deadline for uh reporting on all house
bills Senate
okay you want me to go online I think
can you read
that house deadlines
2024 last day uh to act on Senate Bills
going to a second committee which we've
already done which is tomorrow Friday
Thursday that's the 20 last St act on
all Senate bills is
May May 2
16th May 23rd is the last day that's the
last day to act yeah we need the report
the last day report is 16th
what's
that I'm looking at the rest of when I'm
coming